programming throwdown episode 50 congratulations take it away j Hey, everybody. This is a special episode of Programming Throwdown. And, you know, if this is your first time listening to a Programming Throwdown episode, we typically talk about a different language or computational concept every show. We start off with some news, tell some jokes, things like that. We're not doing any of that this show. So if this is your first show that you've listened to, if you're brand new to Programming Throwdown, hit pause, go back a few episodes, check out one of our other ones.
Programming Throwdown 第50期，恭喜，开始吧。嘿，大家好。这是 Programming Throwdown 的一期特别节目。你知道，如果这是你第一次收听 Programming Throwdown，我们通常会在每期节目中讨论一种不同的语言或计算概念。我们以一些新闻开始，讲些笑话之类的。但这期节目我们不打算这样做。所以，如果你是第一次收听，如果你是 Programming Throwdown 的新听众，请按暂停，回去听几期之前的节目，看看我们其他的作品。
This is really just a special episode that we want to do for our fans, give them the opportunity to ask questions, make comments, and we'll read them on the air. And so we're also broadcasting this particular episode live on livecoding.tv slash neural nets for life, the number four. And we'll give a link to it in the show notes and all of that. But that means that we're gonna be fielding some questions
这真的是我们想为粉丝们制作的一期特别节目，给他们机会提问、发表评论，我们会在节目中读出来。所以我们也在 livecoding.tv/neuralnetsforlife（数字4）上直播这期节目。我们会在节目说明中提供链接。这意味着我们将回答一些问题。
from the live audience. And so that we're going to be fielding some questions from the live audience. And so that might cause us to, for one, it's definitely all one take. It usually is anyways. We always record this. People don't know that maybe, actually. Yeah, good point. We always record in one take unless something really, really bad happens, which has only happened like once or twice where we've had problems.
来自现场观众的问题。所以，我们将会回答一些来自现场观众的问题。这可能会导致我们，首先，这绝对是一次录制完成的。通常情况下也是这样。我们总是这样录音。人们可能不知道这一点，其实。是的，说得好。我们总是录制一次，除非发生非常非常糟糕的事情，这种情况只发生过一两次，我们遇到过问题。
But otherwise, it's one take all the way straight through, almost no editing, slap on the beginning and the end, which hopefully the beginning part has gotten a little better. I think people used to not like it. Yeah, yeah, definitely have tightened that up. Early, early, yeah, totally. So in this episode, we're going to kind of talk about the history of the show and everything, give you guys an insight. I've heard to say folks instead of guys. Folks.
但除此之外，它是一次录制到底，几乎没有剪辑，只加上开头和结尾，希望开头部分已经有所改进。我想人们过去不喜欢它。是的，是的，绝对已经改进了。早期，是的，完全是。所以在这期节目中，我们将讨论节目的历史以及其他一切，让你们深入了解。我听人说用“folks”（各位）代替“guys”（伙计们）。Folks。
Someone said don't say guys. Is that more politically correct? Say folks or yous, which I just can't do yous. Y'all? They also said y'all. I don't think I can do y'all either. All right, y'all. Let's get this started.
有人说不要说“guys”。那样在政治上更正确吗？说“folks”或者“yous”，但我实在说不出“yous”。“Y'all”？他们也说了“y'all”。我想我也说不出“y'all”。好吧，各位，让我们开始吧。
I've relegated myself to folks. We'll give you folks an opportunity to ask us anything you want to ask us. And we've gotten a ton of questions and comments. And we're just going gonna kind of go through it and also field some from the chat as we go. All right, the first one is one we've gotten several times, and we're gonna only give the partial answer to, so apologies.
我把自己降级为说“folks”。我们会给各位一个机会问我们任何想问的问题。我们收到了大量的提问和评论。我们将逐一浏览，并在此过程中回答聊天室的一些问题。好的，第一个问题是我们收到过好几次的，我们只会给出部分答案，所以抱歉。
And sometimes there's been multiple questions, and I sort of randomly picked a person to represent that question. And we didn't cover all questions. There are many, many questions about, will you cover topic X or Y? So those are left out. Don't feel bad if you email us with those.
有时会有多个问题，我随机挑选了一个人来代表那个问题。我们没有涵盖所有问题。有很多关于“你们会讨论X或Y主题吗？”的问题。所以那些被略过了。如果你给我们发邮件问这些，不要感到难过。
Hopefully, we'll cover all those eventually. Yeah, we've gotten so many people saying, will you cover Ruby? We will cover Ruby, but not today. All right, so our first question is from Mariano. And they say, I have a question. I have friends that are taking courses in edX.org, CodeAcademy.com, Lynda.com, which are very useful websites to learn as a beginner going towards advance. Being that the job market for programmers are majority looking for a BA or MA,
希望我们最终能涵盖所有这些。是的，我们收到很多人问“你们会讨论Ruby吗？”。我们会讨论Ruby，但不是今天。好的，所以我们的第一个问题来自Mariano。他们说，我有一个问题。我有朋友正在edX.org、CodeAcademy.com、Lynda.com上学习课程，这些是非常有用的初学者到进阶的学习网站。鉴于程序员的就业市场大多要求学士或硕士学位，
a bachelor or master's degree in computer science, would it be tough to get hired by learning to code on your own? Or what would be your experience? And that's Mariano. Cool, Mariano. You're the first question of the show. Congratulations. Fanfare.
计算机科学的学士或硕士学位，自学编程会很难被录用吗？或者你们的经验是什么？那是Mariano。酷，Mariano。你是本节目的第一个问题。恭喜。欢呼声。
So basically, this is a great question. I actually thought a lot about this. I asked a variety of people, personal friends and colleagues. There's sort of an inflection point here. Think about it. Five, 10 years ago, there was really only lynda.com. There wasn't Coursera or –
所以基本上，这是一个很好的问题。我实际上思考了很多。我问了各种各样的人，个人朋友和同事。这里有一个转折点。想一想。五、十年前，真的只有lynda.com。没有Coursera或者——
When this podcast started, we didn't have smartphones. That's right. Or we had just gotten them. I think you had just gotten one. I didn't have one. I think what the iPhone, like, 3GS was out or something. Yeah, something like that. But, yeah, basically, you know, since then, a lot has changed.
当这个播客开始时，我们还没有智能手机。没错。或者我们刚得到它们。我想你刚得到一个。我没有。我想当时iPhone 3GS什么的已经出来了。是的，类似那样。但是，是的，基本上，你知道，从那时起，很多事情都变了。
It's changing very rapidly. And a lot of people are saying, look, Coursera has these amazing courses. They're taught by MIT professors. But, you know, when I apply for a job, you know, or if I'm hiring somebody, you know, how can I kind of take it seriously? You know, what's the accreditation level and things like that? It's a very difficult question. This is the way I break it down. If you have a bachelor's or a master's degree,
变化非常迅速。很多人说，看，Coursera有这些很棒的课程。它们是由麻省理工学院的教授教授的。但是，你知道，当我申请工作时，或者如果我在招聘某人时，你知道，我怎么能认真对待它呢？你知道，认证水平之类的东西是什么？这是一个非常困难的问题。这是我的分析方式。如果你有学士或硕士学位，
that's always the gold standard. There are accredited universities and that's always gonna be the best thing. If you don't have that, it's good to have good background with Coursera, Udacity, these courses, combined with an active history on something like GitHub, right? So if you have a GitHub with a bunch of repositories, you've contributed a lot, you are one of the authors of Homebrew or something like that, and you have some Coursera courses just to show that you picked up the fundamentals,
那永远是黄金标准。有认证的大学，那永远是最好的。如果你没有，最好有Coursera、Udacity这些课程的良好背景，结合像GitHub这样平台上的活跃历史，对吧？所以如果你有一个拥有大量存储库的GitHub，你贡献了很多，你是Homebrew的作者之一之类的，并且你有一些Coursera课程来证明你掌握了基础知识，
then I think even if you don't have the college degree, I think you'll still get noticed. And that's really the key. Once you're in an interview setting, your resume isn't as important. Most people will, you know, jump straight into most people already know what three questions like they're going to ask you. Hopefully not the fizz buzz question and, you know, some dynamic programming question. They know already what they're going to ask you. And if they see that you have a bachelor's in psychology, they're not going to redo the whole interview. But the key is, how do you get to the interview stage with, and I have nothing against psychology, but how do you get to the interview stage with, you know,
那么我认为即使你没有大学学位，我想你仍然会被注意到。这才是关键。一旦你进入面试阶段，你的简历就不那么重要了。大多数人会，你知道，直接跳到大多数人已经知道他们要问你的三个问题。希望不是Fizz Buzz问题和，你知道，一些动态规划问题。他们已经知道他们要问什么了。如果他们看到你有一个心理学学士学位，他们不会重做整个面试。但关键是，你如何进入面试阶段，我并不反对心理学，但你如何进入面试阶段，你知道，
a bachelor's that's not CS or engineering? And so I think, again, you know, GitHub links should be the first thing on your resume, bunch of repositories, bunch of open source contributions, and the Coursera courses. And I think that can get your foot in the door repositories, bunch of open source contributions, and the Coursera courses, and I think that can get your foot in the door. Yeah, I would agree. I think it'll be very difficult for having a boot camp
一个非计算机科学或工程学的学士学位？所以我认为，再次强调，你知道，GitHub链接应该是你简历上的第一件事，一堆存储库，一堆开源贡献，以及Coursera课程。我认为这可以让你敲开大门。是的，我同意。我认为对于参加训练营来说会非常困难，
or Udacity, even with their certificates and stuff, which they're getting better. And in five years, this show may just seem completely dated. You pointed that out, that this completely changes. But having worked for, with, and talking to people who also work at large companies, at least, there's a lot of filters because you get a lot of junk resumes in.
或者Udacity，即使有他们的证书之类的，它们正在变得更好。五年后，这个节目可能看起来完全过时了。你指出了这一点，这完全改变了。但是，在大型公司工作过、共事过并与在那里工作的人交谈过，至少，有很多过滤器，因为你会收到很多垃圾简历。
And it's, as you said, how do you get into the, let's talk to these people. Because once they talk to you, they may find out you're a great person, they'll hire you, whatever. But how do you get into that pile? How do you get past that filter? And as you said, it's going to be really hard. So I think somewhat you actually have, I don't know,
而且，正如你所说，你怎么进入那个阶段，让我们和这些人谈谈。因为一旦他们和你谈话，他们可能会发现你是一个很棒的人，他们会雇佣你，等等。但你怎么进入那个堆栈？你怎么通过那个过滤器？正如你所说，这会非常困难。所以我认为某种程度上你实际上有，我不知道，
I've never done this, but I would assume it may be something you have to take a chance on, like you have to take a job that isn't the job you would necessarily want for pay. You might not necessarily want the GitHub stuff is, is great. And that is necessary, but ultimately somebody is going to have to take the first risk on you yeah the thing about the Bachelor of Science or masters or BA or whatever bachelor's degree or master's degree or PhD is that you at least had the tenacity to stick through University which is notoriously grueling you know to various degrees depending on the university and so the company is taking a bet that that is correlated with your ability
我从来没做过这个，但我会假设这可能是你必须冒险的事情，比如你必须接受一份你未必想要的薪水工作。你可能未必想要，GitHub的东西很棒。这是必要的，但最终有人必须为你承担第一次风险。是的，关于理学学士或硕士或文学学士或任何学士学位或硕士学位或博士学位的事情是，你至少有坚持完成大学学业的韧性，这在不同程度上是出了名的艰苦，取决于大学，所以公司在打赌这与你的能力相关，
to stick it and at least learn something and be productive at the company. And if you miss that, it's much harder. Not impossible, but it is much, much harder. And so you're going to have to do something to get your foot in the door. And that may mean taking a job that is, you know, you just volunteer, like, for instance, to code for maybe a volunteer organization or a startup, you know, that's local to your area where, you know, hang out with them and like try to get involved there. And even if they don't pay you, but at least you can start to
坚持下去，至少学到一些东西并在公司里有成效。如果你错过了这一点，就难多了。不是不可能，但确实难得多。所以你必须做点什么来敲开大门。这可能意味着接受一份工作，你知道，你只是志愿服务，例如，为志愿者组织或初创公司编写代码，你知道，在你当地的，你知道，和他们一起闲逛，试着参与其中。即使他们不付钱给你，但至少你可以开始
and not just say like, oh, hey, I worked for these people when you didn't, but get them to actually acknowledge your contribution so that you can honestly say like, hey, I worked for this company. Yep. Yep. I know a lot of people at Mozilla are people who contributed massively to Firefox. I mean, it's kind of, it's obvious when you think about it, but it's true. And now, you know, a lot of them also have degrees and things like that.
不仅仅是说，哦，嘿，我为这些人工作过，当你没有的时候，而是让他们真正承认你的贡献，这样你就可以诚实地说，嘿，我为这家公司工作过。是的。是的。我知道Mozilla的很多人都是为Firefox做出巨大贡献的人。我的意思是，当你想到它时，这很明显，但这是真的。现在，你知道，他们中的许多人也有学位之类的。
But I think that showing a lot of contribution to some, one thing that a lot of people don't know, and we've talked about it several times, but it's been a while now, is a lot of these open source projects are really run by large companies. I mean, if you look at LibreOffice or Java
但我认为展示对某事的巨大贡献，很多人不知道的一件事，我们已经讨论过好几次了，但已经有一段时间了，是很多这些开源项目实际上是由大公司运营的。我的意思是，如果你看看LibreOffice或Java，
is run, like IBM and Oracle are the two main contributors to Java, right? To the JVM. And so you're contributing to those product, open source projects directly connects you with a lot of engineers in the industry. So that's something to keep in mind. Yeah. And those engineers can put in your resume and an engineer putting in your resume, having noticed you is always going to be better than applying
是由IBM和Oracle运营的，它们是Java的两个主要贡献者，对吧？对JVM。所以你为这些产品、开源项目做出贡献，直接让你与行业中的许多工程师联系起来。所以这是需要记住的。是的。而且那些工程师可以提交你的简历，而工程师提交你的简历，注意到你，总是比盲目申请要好。
blindly. So that's another tip is like, if you know someone, always have them put in your resume because that universally leads to better results in my experience. And we should also preface someone pointed out in the chat room that most of our advice is oriented to the U.S. Some of it may be applicable elsewhere, but, you know, Jason and I both live in the U.S. and I have lived in the U.S. all my life. And so I don't know, other countries may or may not be different in varying degrees. So that is a caveat. A lot of people do listen from outside the U.S. and we're thankful to have you guys. Definitely. Definitely. Awesome. So I'll read the next question and I'll go ahead and start answering it. You can find maybe a question from
所以这是另一个建议，如果你认识某人，总是让他们提交你的简历，因为根据我的经验，这通常会导致更好的结果。我们还应该说明，聊天室里有人指出，我们的大部分建议都是针对美国的。其中一些可能适用于其他地方，但是，你知道，杰森和我都在美国生活，我一生都住在美国。所以我不确定，其他国家在不同程度上可能会有所不同。所以这是一个警告。很多人确实从美国以外收听，我们很感谢你们。绝对。绝对。太棒了。所以我来读下一个问题，我会开始回答它。你可以找一个聊天室的问题来跟进。
the chat room to follow up with. Okay. All right. So this is from Ashley and they say, first, what is the story behind Programming Throwdown? What made you decide to get together and make a podcast on programming? I assume Ashley probably had other questions and I probably clipped them out for time. But the story behind Programming Throwdown is Jason and I used to work at a company together
好的。好的。所以这是来自Ashley的，他们说，首先，Programming Throwdown背后的故事是什么？是什么让你决定聚在一起制作一个关于编程的播客？我假设Ashley可能还有其他问题，我可能为了时间把它们剪掉了。但Programming Throwdown背后的故事是杰森和我曾经在一家公司一起工作，
and we would kind of talk a lot about topics related to work, related to programming, but not, you know, just about, you know, the stuff we were working on, and realized we both had a passion for this and said, you know, kind of like people say, how do we do open source?
我们会谈论很多与工作相关、与编程相关的话题，但不是，你知道，只是关于，你知道，我们正在做的事情，并意识到我们俩对此都有热情，并说，你知道，就像人们说的，我们怎么做开源？
How do we do whatever? And Jason does a little more open source than I do almost. I do none, not almost none, actually none. And so it was like, how do I get involved? I don't really want to do open source. That's not the way I roll. And so one of the things we talked it was like how do I get involved I don't really want to do open source that's not the way I roll and so one of the things we talked about like hey we could have a podcast at the time it was kind of like hey there are these school podcasts I listen to a couple let's do one like why not yep and
我们怎么做任何事？杰森做的开源比我多一点。我什么都不做，几乎什么都不做，其实什么都不做。所以就像，我怎么参与进来？我真的不想做开源。那不是我的风格。所以我们谈论的一件事就像，我们可以做一个播客，当时就像，嘿，有这些很酷的播客，我听了几个，让我们做一个，为什么不呢？是的，而且
from my perspective I really I had two choices I could either become a teacher or I could go into industry and I decided to go into industry but I still really love teaching. And this was a way for us to both teach something while still being in industry and being able to work on just very large projects with lots of people. And a way to stand out as well, right? So we do the podcast, we get to teach, we get to do something we enjoy. I didn't, to be honest, think it would last 50 episodes. I didn't think it would last five episodes. I think most people say episodes die, I think, before 10. So you can't say you're doing a podcast until you've gotten to 10. So you're on past 10. Maybe someone else
从我的角度来看，我真的有两个选择，我可以成为一名教师，或者我可以进入行业，我决定进入行业，但我仍然非常喜欢教学。这是我们俩在进入行业的同时教点东西，并能够与许多人一起处理非常大的项目的一种方式。这也是一种脱颖而出的方式，对吧？所以我们做播客，我们有机会教学，我们有机会做我们喜欢的事情。老实说，我没想到它会持续50期。我没想到它会持续5期。我想大多数人说播客在10期之前就死了。所以你不能说你在做播客，直到你达到10期。所以你已经超过10期了。也许别人
will tell us you can't be a podcast for reals until you get to 100. Maybe. So we've done it past 10. It hasn't always been as regular or irregular. But I think one of the things is to stick out, right? So people say, what makes what makes you different? What, you know, if you have a passion, often people say you'll code whether someone pays you to or not. That may or may not be true due to various life circumstances. I don't happen to do that much coding in my off time, but I do this, right? This is a similar outlet for me. I talk about programming and talk about tech. I teach, you know, so that's kind of the story. That's not a great idea. And then just kept doing it even at one point Jason was in California and I was in Florida we were doing it now we're both out here in Silicon Valley we
会告诉我们，直到你达到100期，你才算是一个真正的播客。也许吧。所以我们已经超过10期了。它并不总是那么规律或不规律。但我认为其中一件事是坚持下去，对吧？所以人们说，是什么让你与众不同？什么，你知道，如果你有热情，人们通常说无论是否有人付钱给你，你都会写代码。由于各种生活环境，这可能是真的也可能不是。我碰巧在业余时间不做那么多编码，但我做这个，对吧？这对我来说是一个类似的出口。我谈论编程，谈论技术。我教学，你知道，所以这就是故事。这不是一个好主意。然后只是继续做，甚至有一次杰森在加利福尼亚，我在佛罗里达，我们正在做，现在我们都在硅谷，我们
work at different companies and we still do it yep so it's just kind of stuck with us they're thinking that no you're thinking didn't so yeah in sickness or in health actually no terrible we're no, no. Actually, no. That's terrible. We're not married. When we're sick, we definitely don't do the podcast. Yeah. So, yeah, definitely the motivation for us is the feedback that we get. I mean, we get so many people who are saying, we got someone yesterday saying, you know, I'm an engineer in Kenya and I don't have, he said he didn't have as many resources as he feels like a lot of people have access to, but he does have access to this podcast. And so that was kind of powerful. You know, I mean, the fact that we could spend some time and hopefully bootstrap somebody who has an incredible amount of passion and might not have the right resources or or or
在不同的公司工作，我们仍然在做。是的，所以它只是伴随着我们。他们认为不，你认为没有。所以是的，在疾病或健康中，其实不，太糟糕了，我们不，不。其实不。那太糟糕了。我们没有结婚。当我们生病时，我们绝对不做播客。是的。所以，是的，绝对是我们得到的反馈激励了我们。我的意思是，我们收到很多人说，我们昨天收到某人说，你知道，我是肯尼亚的一名工程师，我没有，他说他没有像他觉得很多人能接触到的那么多资源，但他确实能接触到这个播客。所以这很有力量。你知道，我的意思是，我们可以花一些时间，希望能够帮助一个拥有巨大热情，可能没有合适资源的人，或者
somebody who has a great background in one field and wants to you know make a change and or someone who's in school and doesn't know what major they want to pick I mean these are all people who hopefully we've we've helped some of them you them through encouragement and through education. We've helped some of them make their decisions. Or just helping people pass time. Yeah, that's right. Like not be bored or laugh at us for how terrible this is. Whatever.
一个在一个领域有很好背景并想，你知道，做出改变的人，或者一个在学校里不知道想选什么专业的人，我的意思是，这些人都是我们希望通过鼓励和教育帮助过他们中的一些人。我们帮助他们中的一些人做出了决定。或者只是帮助人们打发时间。是的，没错。就像不感到无聊或嘲笑我们有多糟糕。无论如何。
It's all good. I wonder if it's gotten better. The number of people laughing at us has gotten higher? That's definitely true. Okay, okay. So the sheer number of people laughing at us has gotten higher? That's definitely true. Okay, okay. So the sheer number of people laughing at us has gone up orders of magnitude. Yes!
都很好。我不知道它是否变好了。嘲笑我们的人数变多了？那绝对是真的。好的，好的。所以嘲笑我们的人数变多了？那绝对是真的。好的，好的。所以嘲笑我们的人数增加了几个数量级。是的！
Because, you know, the first episode was just our moms laughing at us. And now there's thousands of people laughing. My mom told me she didn't make it through the whole first episode. I know, mine too. She's like, you boys are so sweet. But yeah, I couldn't listen to more than 10 minutes.
因为，你知道，第一期节目只是我们的妈妈在嘲笑我们。现在有成千上万的人在嘲笑。我妈妈告诉我她没听完第一期节目。我知道，我妈妈也是。她说，你们这些男孩真可爱。但是是的，我听不到10分钟以上。
Uh, yeah. But yeah, basically it's feedback from you guys. You know, for people who are brand new, uh, um, subscribers, uh, you know, we have programmingthrowdown.com. We have Twitter, we have Facebook, we have Google plus, we have email. Uh, yeah, I, uh, I'm a social maven, although I don't, uh, post as much as I probably should. I'm a recluse. Um, but yeah, Patrick has none of this.
呃，是的。但是是的，基本上这是来自你们的反馈。你知道，对于全新的订阅者，呃，嗯，你知道，我们有programmingthrowdown.com。我们有Twitter，我们有Facebook，我们有Google plus，我们有电子邮件。呃，是的，我，呃，我是一个社交达人，虽然我没有，呃，发布得像我应该的那样多。我是一个隐士。嗯，但是是的，帕特里克没有这些。
So actually, it's amazing. Patrick, you have to email him directly. Do you have anything besides email? I have Google+. Oh, OK. People follow me occasionally on Google+, but I don't post. I'm a terrible person. Got it, got it.
所以其实，这很神奇。帕特里克，你必须直接给他发电子邮件。除了电子邮件你还有什么吗？我有Google+。哦，好的。人们偶尔在Google+上关注我，但我从不发布。我是一个糟糕的人。明白了，明白了。
But yeah, definitely give us your feedback, questions, comments. That's what drives us. So cool. Next question is, we'll take one from the chat someone said how many female engineers are there in embedded mobile web etc we'll just say in programming the short answer is not enough right I mean the ratio of female to male in software engineering is not 50-50.
但是是的，一定要给我们你的反馈、问题、评论。这就是驱动我们的动力。太酷了。下一个问题是，我们将从聊天室中选一个，有人问嵌入式、移动端、Web等领域有多少女性工程师？我们只说在编程领域，简短的回答是不够的，对吧？我的意思是，软件工程中女性与男性的比例不是50-50。
But there are a lot of great programs. I feel like this is something. So I have sort of two thoughts on this. One is this is something that's going to just get better over time. I think that every generation, if you look at, if you compare yourself to your parents and to their parents and to your kids, right, every generation has sort of a different understanding of humanity. So you're saying people become more... Okay.
但有很多很棒的项目。我觉得这是某件事。所以我对此有两种想法。一是这是随着时间推移会变得更好的事情。我认为每一代人，如果你看看，如果你把自己和你的父母、他们的父母以及你的孩子相比，对吧，每一代人对人性都有不同的理解。所以你是说人们变得更……好的。
Really? Let's hear the second point. Let's hear the second point. Okay. Well, I just feel like things are on a good place, sort of on a good path there. I think that things are becoming more accepting. I think it's important that we're recognizing it's a problem. Right.
真的吗？让我们听听第二点。让我们听听第二点。好的。嗯，我只是觉得事情处于一个好的位置，某种程度上处于一个好的轨道上。我认为事情变得更加包容。我认为重要的是我们认识到这是一个问题。对。
That's a good first step. Yep. I'll agree. So I feel like things are getting better passively, but I do think we need to take more action to sort of help this because it needs some bootstrapping. It needs some acceleration. Otherwise, it will just be floating in this one direction that's been in for a long time. So there are definitely a lot of efforts. I think actually the Raspberry Pi Foundation donated a bunch of money to this,
这是一个好的第一步。是的。我同意。所以我感觉事情正在被动地变好，但我确实认为我们需要采取更多行动来帮助这一点，因为它需要一些引导。它需要一些加速。否则，它只会一直漂浮在这个已经存在很长时间的方向上。所以肯定有很多努力。我想其实Raspberry Pi基金会捐了一大笔钱给这个，
I think it's Girls That Code. And it's a charity event that, a charity foundation that hosts a bunch of events to try and get more females into software engineering, developing, coding, things like that. There's also, there's a couple of other efforts. I can't think of them off the top of my head. It's like Grace, Chen.
我想是Girls That Code。这是一个慈善活动，一个慈善基金会，举办了一堆活动，试图让更多的女性进入软件工程、开发、编码等领域。还有，还有其他几个努力。我一时想不起来了。就像Grace, Chen。
I think I'll agree that it is a problem, and we are beginning to take the steps to try to address it. But I think with anything, it's a long pipeline. I think a lot of studies show that decisions about kind of what general areas you'll go into, what kind of fields, or at least for some fields like engineering, math, computer science, are made as early as like middle school. And so unfortunately, if you kind of say everyone past middle school is going to be very low conversion ratio of fixing the problem, right, then unfortunately, that means it's going to take many years of concerted, continuous and deliberate effort. And so it's not something that we can expect to change overnight by just simply throwing money at the problem. It's something we have to
我想我会同意这是一个问题，我们正在开始采取步骤试图解决它。但我认为对于任何事情，这都是一个漫长的管道。我认为很多研究表明，关于你将进入什么一般领域、什么样领域的决定，或者至少对于工程、数学、计算机科学等领域，早在初中就做出了。所以不幸的是，如果你说初中以后的每个人都将是解决问题的低转化率，对吧，那么不幸的是，这意味着需要多年的协调、持续和深思熟虑的努力。所以这不是我们可以指望通过简单地向问题投入资金就能在一夜之间改变的事情。这是我们必须
cultivate. And, you know, so I have two daughters, right? So thinking through like, how do I enable them that if they want to do this as a career, like how to make sure that they don't get told otherwise, right? Or how to make sure that they're encouraged and supported. Right. Um, and those are things you have to culture over a long time. So I think it's going to be a long road and I hope, I don't trust like you that it just by nature will get better, but it seems like we're starting to recognize it's a problem and hopefully enact changes that'll improve things. Cool. And someone just posted in the chat, I think it's girl develop it. I think that's actually the foundation that I was thinking of.
培养的。而且，你知道，所以我有两个女儿，对吧？所以思考一下，我如何确保如果她们想把这作为职业，我如何确保她们不会被告知不可以，对吧？或者如何确保她们得到鼓励和支持。对。嗯，这些是你必须长期培养的事情。所以我认为这将是一条漫长的道路，我希望，我不像你那样相信它自然会变好，但看起来我们开始认识到这是一个问题，并希望制定能改善事情的变革。酷。有人刚在聊天室里发了，我想是girl develop it。我想那实际上就是我正在想的基金会。
They got it correct. Yep, that's it. So yeah, so girl develop it. There might even be another one, but. I think there's several others, but yeah. Cool. All right, so next one we have is, this is so, we had this from a lot of people.
他们答对了。是的，就是那个。所以是的，所以girl develop it。可能还有另一个，但是。我想还有其他几个，但是是的。酷。好的，所以下一个我们有的是，这是所以，我们从很多人那里得到了这个。
I didn't even actually go and find some specific one, but this is you guys have this from a lot of people i didn't even actually go and find some specific one but this is you guys to talk too much or too little about the news or programming languages uh i'd like you to talk more or less about the news the programming language is the book um so like again this is like i guess you call it insider baseball behind the scenes about how this podcast is recorded but i mean, the podcast is something we do. We don't really get paid for it. We have some like the Patreon stuff and the Amazon
我甚至没有去寻找特定的一个，但这是你们从很多人那里得到的，我甚至没有去寻找特定的一个，但这是你们谈论新闻或编程语言太多或太少，呃，我希望你们多谈或少谈新闻、编程语言、书，嗯，所以就像再次，我想你称之为内部棒球，关于这个播客是如何录制的幕后花絮，但我的意思是，播客是我们做的事情。我们并没有真正从中得到报酬。我们有一些像Patreon的东西和亚马逊
and your all the subscriptions. We're very thankful for all of that. And that helps encourage us, you know, to a large degree to keep going. And pays our costs. It actually is significantly expensive to, I mean, we,
以及你们所有的订阅。我们非常感谢所有这些。这在很大程度上鼓励我们继续前进。并支付我们的成本。它实际上非常昂贵，我的意思是，我们，
I checked last month, we used four terabytes of bandwidth last month. Oh, yes. Like one cat video on YouTube. Yeah, that's right. And so these things are encouraging to us, but ultimately it's something we have to enjoy
我上个月查了一下，我们上个月用了4TB的带宽。哦，是的。就像YouTube上的一个猫视频。是的，没错。所以这些事情对我们来说是鼓励，但最终这是我们必须享受的事情
because if we don't enjoy it, we're not going to do it. This isn't replacing our jobs, right? So we have our jobs. We both have families. And so we need to enjoy doing this. And one of the things we enjoy is just like chatting about tech stuff. Like that's what we do. That's who we are.
因为如果我们不享受它，我们就不会做它。这并没有取代我们的工作，对吧？所以我们有我们的工作。我们都有家庭。所以我们需要享受做这件事。我们享受的事情之一就是聊天技术方面的东西。就像那是我们做的。那是我们是谁。
And so this podcast is an extension of that. Also, it turns out it's actually really difficult to talk at length about a lot of the topics, the programming languages. So we try to do a good job. We try to cover it. But ultimately, there are other podcasts I've listened to where it's all about a single topic and they talk the whole thing and I find myself drifting off like it's not the same this isn't to that podcast we're sorry if you don't like it we'll give you your money back you didn't pay for it
所以这个播客是它的延伸。此外，事实证明，详细谈论很多话题、编程语言实际上非常困难。所以我们尽量做得好。我们尽量涵盖它。但最终，我听过其他播客，它们全是关于一个单一主题，他们谈论整个事情，我发现自己走神了，就像它不一样，这不是那个播客，如果你不喜欢它，我们很抱歉，我们会退还你的钱，你没有付钱
but you know ultimately the balance we try to strike is covering topics that are interesting to people in the field of programming giving you a little you know tidbit about something we're not trying to bury the lead we're not trying to make you go through all the other stuff we could cover it in the beginning, but it would mess up kind of our flow.
但是，你知道，最终我们试图达到的平衡是涵盖编程领域人们感兴趣的话题，给你一点，你知道，关于某事的点滴，我们不是试图掩盖重点，我们不是试图让你经历所有其他事情，我们可以在开始时涵盖它，但这会弄乱我们的流程。
Like we need that other stuff as like a warmup. And as we said, we take this in one take. So we would have a hard time not referencing stuff we already talked about. And then it would be all like confusing. And we'd have, so yeah, that's just not. We tried it. We thought about it.
就像我们需要其他东西作为热身。正如我们所说，我们一次录制完成。所以我们很难不引用我们已经谈过的事情。然后它会变得非常混乱。我们会，所以是的，那只是不行。我们试过了。我们考虑过它。
And yeah, it just doesn't work. It just doesn't work. So we have to do the news and the other stuff first, because that's the progression that works for us. And if we talk too much about it and too little about the other thing, you know, sorry. There's always next episode. Yeah.
而且是的，它就是不行。它就是不行。所以我们必须先做新闻和其他事情，因为那是对我们有效的进展。如果我们谈论它太多，而谈论另一件事太少，你知道，抱歉。总有下一期。是的。
The idea is just to leave you with a tidbit, a morsel, something. Hopefully you walk away with something you didn't know. Right. And then if we ever, you know, now that we're 50 in, I guess we have self-granted permission to go back and revisit some topics. And so maybe we can get into more specific aspects. And I think that's something we should do. So like specific parts of C++ or C or the things we're really into, it'll be, you know, cover those in more detail. The other things may or may not get revisited. We'll see 50 is a lot, but there's a lot to come, lots to still
这个想法只是给你留下一个点滴，一个碎片，某样东西。希望你离开时带走了一些你不知道的东西。对。然后如果我们曾经，你知道，现在我们已经50期了，我想我们有自我授予的许可回去重温一些话题。所以也许我们可以进入更具体的方面。我认为这是我们应该做的。所以像C++或C的具体部分，或者我们真正感兴趣的事情，它会是，你知道，更详细地涵盖那些。其他事情可能会也可能不会被重温。我们会看到50是一个很大的数字，但还有很多要来，很多仍然要
cover. Definitely. I mean, the other part of it too is the audience is kind of different. You know, I mean, a lot of the people who write in and they say, you know, I really love Python. I think Python is such an awesome language. You know, it only got 15 minutes in one episode. And we love Python too. The issue is there's many people who are just getting into this for the first time. And if we really dive into, oh, you know, why you have to use multiprocessing instead of multithreading so you don't get the, you know, GIL, you know, the global interpreter lock in Python, then it kind of loses the spirit of the show,
涵盖。绝对。我的意思是，它的另一部分也是观众有点不同。你知道，我的意思是，很多写信进来的人，他们说，你知道，我真的很喜欢Python。我认为Python是一门很棒的语言。你知道，它在一期节目中只得到了15分钟。我们也喜欢Python。问题是有很多人是第一次接触这个。如果我们真的深入研究，哦，你知道，为什么你必须使用多进程而不是多线程，这样你就不会得到，你知道，GIL，你知道，Python中的全局解释器锁，那么它就失去了节目的精神，
which is to show you enough about a language that you get really excited or enough about a language where you can give you a foothold where then you can scale that mountain of being an expert in that field. Yeah, I mean, in an ideal world, I guess we could do two podcasts. And one would be for teaching beginners, people not in the field or people just looking to commute. And then another would be in-depth, hard topics. Right. And hopefully wouldn't fall asleep. But well, there's plenty of people are really good at that second one, I think. Yeah, I think there's other topics. And then also,
那就是向你展示足够多的关于一门语言的内容，让你感到非常兴奋，或者足够多的关于一门语言的内容，可以给你一个立足点，然后你就可以攀登成为该领域专家的那座山。是的，我的意思是，在一个理想的世界里，我想我们可以做两个播客。一个是为了教初学者，不在该领域的人或只是想通勤的人。然后另一个将是深入、困难的话题。对。希望不会睡着。但嗯，有很多人非常擅长第二个，我想。是的，我认为还有其他话题。然后还有，
I'm not sure, like, although it sounds good to say, like, if you actually sat and listened to it, if you would be really into it. Yeah, I think it's much faster to look at for me, at least I need to these things like we talk about are good for me to listen to. But like when gets too detailed i need to see it in front of me i'm a visual guy i guess same here same here cool uh so we'll take one from the chat this is an easy one uh where are you from so i'll go first um i was born uh in canada i lived in canada until i was about 10, moved to Florida. I lived in Italy for about three or four months, then moved back to Florida and then to California. Well, I didn't know all that.
我不确定，就像，虽然说起来很好听，就像，如果你真的坐下来听它，你是否会真的很喜欢它。是的，我认为对我来说，看它快得多，至少我需要这些我们谈论的事情对我来说听起来很好。但是当变得太详细时，我需要在我面前看到它，我猜我是一个视觉型的人，我也是，我也是，酷，呃，所以我们将从聊天室中选一个，这是一个简单的问题，呃，你来自哪里，所以我先来，嗯，我出生，呃，在加拿大，我住在加拿大直到我大约10岁，搬到佛罗里达。我在意大利住了大约三四个月，然后搬回佛罗里达，然后搬到加利福尼亚。嗯，我不知道所有这些。
Yeah. I knew some of it. So I was born and raised in Florida and moved to California when I started my current job. So, yeah, it's pretty boring. Yeah. Central Florida the whole time. So someone else also asked about VLSC architecture. I didn't see, or VISC.
是的。我知道其中的一些。所以我出生并在佛罗里达长大，当我开始目前的工作时搬到了加利福尼亚。所以，是的，这很无聊。是的，整个时间都在佛罗里达中部。所以有人也问了关于VLSC架构。我没看到，或者VISC。
I just looked up what that was. So I didn't know what it was. So I can't say anything intelligent about it, but maybe I'll read the article offline. Okay. That will be one of our news topics. News topics. And we'll spend the whole hour talking about it.
我刚查了那是什么。所以我不知道它是什么。所以我不能说任何关于它的聪明话，但也许我会离线阅读这篇文章。好的。那将是我们新闻话题之一。新闻话题。我们将花整个小时谈论它。
All right. So another question someone sent in. Oh, this is the second question from Ashley from above. They wrote, in the last episode, you mentioned how useful it was to have a good knowledge of assembly. I've dabbled in it before, but I'd like to improve my skills. Is there a specific assembler you'd recommend? They've come across several. And is there any good book or learning resource you can recommend for learning assembly?
好的。所以另一个人发来的问题。哦，这是Ashley上面的第二个问题。他们写道，在上一期节目中，你提到了对汇编有很好的了解是多么有用。我以前涉猎过它，但我希望能提高我的技能。有什么具体的汇编器你推荐吗？他们遇到过几个。有什么好的书或学习资源你可以推荐学习汇编吗？
Yes, lots. And I'm sure we could probably try to generate something better, but actually we had another person write in and answered their question unrelatedly. So I'm just going to read their answer. So this is Tim and Tim wrote in to recommend, which I haven't read this book, but it does sound interesting. Charles Petzold's book, Code, the Hidden Language of Computer Hardware and Software. I've heard about this book. And it says, yes, that's the Charles Petzold of programming Windows. And I'm probably not saying the guy's name correctly, but he wrote a little bit, Tim wrote a little bit more about this book and it sounded interesting. I looked at the webpage for it. We'll have it in the show notes.
是的，很多。而且我肯定我们可以尝试生成一些更好的东西，但实际上我们有另一个人写信进来并回答了他们的问题，无关。所以我只是要读他们的答案。所以这是Tim，Tim写信推荐，我没读过这本书，但它听起来确实很有趣。Charles Petzold的书，《Code: The Hidden Language of Computer Hardware and Software》。我听说过这本书。它说，是的，那是编程Windows的Charles Petzold。我可能没有正确说出这个人的名字，但他写了一点，Tim写了一点关于这本书的内容，它听起来很有趣。我看了它的网页。我们会在节目说明中提供它。
That seems interesting. So maybe check out that. There's also several resources for, you know, the interesting thing about assembly is that because the instruction set leads to understanding the architecture, a lot of times there are simulators online. And we'll talk about a little farther down a fun education, fun, but maybe educational way
这看起来很有趣。所以也许看看那个。还有几个资源，你知道，关于汇编有趣的事情是，因为指令集导致了对架构的理解，很多时候网上有模拟器。我们会在后面谈论一个有趣的教育，有趣的，但也许是教育性的方式
of possibly learning assembly a little in a few minutes. But there are lots of simulators and you can use those simulators online and you don't really even need to, like it's cool to write assembly for Windows, but it's really hard because you need to do a lot of stuff. So you really don't want to be doing,
可能在几分钟内学习一点汇编。但有很多模拟器，你可以使用那些在线模拟器，你真的甚至不需要，就像为Windows编写汇编很酷，但它真的很难，因为你需要做很多事情。所以你真的不想做，
or I don't want to be doing that. You want to use a microcontroller or something. Yeah, and even when I write assembly in my day-to-day job, it's always in a very specific context and for a specific reason, I don't start there. And that's because it's a lot of verbosity to really do everything that way. That makes sense. Someone in the chat asked,
或者我不想做那个。你想使用微控制器之类的。是的，即使我在日常工作中编写汇编，它总是在一个非常具体的上下文中，出于特定的原因，我不会从那里开始。这是因为以那种方式真正做所有事情有很多冗长。这说得通。聊天室里有人问，
What programming language paradigms will we see in new programming languages and work their way into existing ones? So this is a pretty tough question to answer on the fly, but I will tell you about one thing that I think is super, super cool. And I've tried to look it up. It's basically a probabilistic programming language. And I had a great article on it, but I don't have it with me at the moment but the idea is all of your variables are actually distributions so you can have a variable that says you know instead of saying X let's say you wanted to roll a die right
我们会在新的编程语言中看到什么编程语言范式，并进入现有的语言？所以这是一个很难在现场回答的问题，但我会告诉你一件我认为超级超级酷的事情。我试着查了一下。它基本上是一种概率编程语言。我有一篇关于它的很棒的文章，但我现在手头没有它，但想法是你的所有变量实际上都是分布，所以你可以有一个变量说，你知道，与其说X，假设你想掷骰子，对吧
but you wanted to have a system that handles you know the dynamics of a die roll right so if you just said X equals you know Rand six you'd get a number a system that handles the dynamics of a die roll, right? So if you just said x equals rand six, you'd get a number between zero and five, right? But in this case, you can actually say x equals uniform distribution from zero through five, and x actually holds that distribution. It doesn't just hold one number from that distribution.
但你想拥有一个处理，你知道，掷骰子动态的系统，对吧？所以如果你只是说X等于，你知道，Rand 6，你会得到一个数字，一个处理掷骰子动态的系统，对吧？所以如果你只是说x等于rand 6，你会得到一个0到5之间的数字，对吧？但在这种情况下，你实际上可以说x等于0到5的均匀分布，并且x实际上持有那个分布。它不仅仅持有来自那个分布的一个数字。
And you can do crazy things like add distributions and things like that and then um there's also pi mc if you if you want to look at a python library that has this but you can do all of this complex math and when you're done you end up with this like really heinous joint distribution and then you can just say you give me the expected value, and it'll go through and crank a bunch of simulations and things like that. But the variables are literally variable.
你可以做疯狂的事情，比如添加分布之类的，然后嗯，如果你想看一个有这个的Python库，还有pi mc，但你可以做所有这些复杂的数学，当你完成后，你最终会得到这个像非常令人发指的联合分布，然后你就可以说你给我期望值，它会经历并进行一堆模拟之类的。但变量字面上是可变的。
The variables are holding... The distribution. The distribution. They're holding the hyperparameters. Interesting. And you do all your programming like that. So I think PyMCMC is one, and there's a bunch of others, but we'll talk about it in a future episode. But I think that is one thing that will kind of get to be more popular
变量持有……分布。分布。它们持有超参数。有趣。你像那样做你所有的编程。所以我认为PyMCMC是一个，还有一堆其他的，但我们会在未来的节目中谈论它。但我认为那是会变得更流行的一件事
as more and more of the world has to deal with noisy data. I mean, anything big data is going to need kind of something like this. Yeah, my thoughts about this is that all the things we see, the functional, the actor stuff, the object-oriented, all of these are trying to say this is the way to solve problems. And I'm increasingly convinced that we're coming to an understanding as a software community that that isn't the right attitude to take. There's not one. And I hope that's one of the things that programming throwdown we mentioned is that most languages have strengths and weaknesses. I don't think all of them have weaknesses.
随着世界上越来越多的人需要处理嘈杂的数据。我的意思是，任何大数据都需要类似这样的东西。是的，我的想法是，我们所看到的一切，函数式、Actor模型、面向对象，所有这些都在试图说这是解决问题的唯一方法。我越来越确信，作为软件社区，我们正在达成一种共识，即这并不是正确的态度。没有唯一的方法。我希望这是我们提到的Programming Throwdown节目中的一点，即大多数语言都有优点和缺点。我不认为它们都有缺点。
I'm not sure all of them have strengths. But all of them have weaknesses. And the idea is I think we're going to move not to one language that's multi-paradigm, like a C++, but instead moving to things where we're able to smoothly move between one and the other. And I think this is things where like, it sounds weird, like Microsoft may
我不确定它们是否都有优点。但它们肯定都有缺点。我认为我们不会转向一种像C++那样多范式的语言，而是会转向能够让我们在不同范式之间平滑切换的事物。我认为这听起来很奇怪，比如微软可能
have been ahead of its time a little, like supporting everything, or even like Java. We have like Java in Scotland, like C Sharp. The C Sharp, J Sharp, all that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right? And even- So just for people who don't know, Microsoft has this thing, what's it called? The dot, well, this.NET framework. Yes. Microsoft has this thing, what's it called? Well, it's a.NET framework. But basically, they took a lot of the existing languages,
有点超前了，比如支持一切，甚至像Java。我们有苏格兰的Java，比如C#。C#，J#，所有这些。是的，是的，是的。对吧？甚至——所以对于那些不知道的人，微软有这个东西，叫什么来着？.NET框架。是的。微软有这个东西，叫什么来着？嗯，它是.NET框架。但基本上，他们采用了许多现有的语言，
C Sharp, J Sharp, which is like a Java kind of knockoff thing, and a bunch of Visual Basic.NET, and all of it compiles down to one common language. It's similar, actually, LLVM is really the same way. Right, so I was going to say, so now that we have LLVM, you have the Clang front end. This is all very similar. And now it's starting to happen on the web a little
C#，J#（这是一种类似Java的仿制品），还有一大堆Visual Basic.NET，所有这些都编译成一种通用语言。其实这很相似，LLVM也是这样。对，我正想说，既然我们有了LLVM，你就有Clang前端。这非常相似。现在这种情况也开始在网络上发生，
where people are writing and it's happening with frameworks in JavaScript. I think, I'm not a big JavaScript, but I kind of see it a little from looking from the outside. Totally. That people are having frameworks
人们正在编写代码，JavaScript框架中也正在发生这种情况。我想，我不是JavaScript的忠实拥护者，但从外部观察，我能看出一点端倪。完全正确。人们拥有
with different paradigms, but they now are interoperating. Like, let's pick the thing that's best for this task instead of trying to do everything in one task. And that's a pro and con. So the con is that now people need to know multiple paradigms and how to program in them and move between them,
不同范式的框架，但它们现在可以互操作了。比如，让我们为这个任务选择最合适的工具，而不是试图用一个任务完成所有事情。这有利有弊。缺点是现在人们需要了解多种范式，知道如何用它们编程并在它们之间切换，
which is very hard, but it has the pro of hopefully using the right tool for the right job. The question becomes how far out of inefficient, how inefficient should you get before you switch to the other thing? And as we make that friction and moving back and forth between them, I think that will be the future where teams won't be able to just do
这非常困难，但优点是希望能为工作选择正确的工具。问题变成了在切换到另一件事之前，你应该达到多大的低效程度？随着我们减少在它们之间来回切换的摩擦，我认为这将是未来，团队将无法再只使用
in one language anymore. But- And things like, you know, protobuf, thrift, and these other technologies that are designed for communicating between processes very efficiently and things like that will make all of that very easy. If you figure, you know, this sort of deep learning package in Python is really great, but all of my code bases in Java, well, it's no big deal, right? You just write some kind of thrift or protobuf RPC layer. And so a lot of that technology is pretty new. I mean, before you would have to do a lot of that by hand. So it lowers the barrier for doing multiple languages on one team. Why do programmers love to hate on PHP and praise Lisp?
一种语言了。但是——像protobuf、thrift以及其他旨在高效进行进程间通信的技术，会让这一切变得非常容易。如果你认为，你知道，Python中的这种深度学习包真的很棒，但我的所有代码库都在Java中，嗯，这没什么大不了的，对吧？你只需要编写某种thrift或protobuf RPC层。所以很多这样的技术还很新。我的意思是，以前你必须手工完成很多工作。因此，它降低了团队使用多种语言的门槛。为什么程序员喜欢抨击PHP而赞美Lisp？
And this is from Ariel. And yeah, so the reason why is because this is just common in what I guess you get into the nerd culture, which is the my way is the best way. Everyone else is, you know, Star Trek is better than Star Wars. No, no, no, Star Wars is better. You know, just getting in that kind of fanboyism is maybe other parts of society have it as well, but I know it's very rampant in tech, and I think it's just that is what you see,
这是Ariel提出的。是的，原因在于这在书呆子文化中很常见，那就是“我的方式是最好的”。其他人，你知道，星际迷航比星球大战好。不，不，不，星球大战更好。你知道，陷入那种粉丝心态，也许社会其他部分也有，但我知道这在科技界非常猖獗，我认为这就是你所看到的，
is that people like to say, oh, PHP is terrible. And it just happens because most people working at the big companies aren't writing in PHP. And so they kind of throw those stones that PHP, from what I understand, I've never done a lot of coding, but does have some flaws,
人们喜欢说，哦，PHP太糟糕了。这之所以发生，是因为大多数在大公司工作的人并没有用PHP编写代码。所以他们有点向PHP投掷石块，据我所知，我从来没有做过大量的编码，但它确实有一些缺陷，
has some problems, has some bad assumptions. They try to fix it, patch it. And ultimately what it ends up is people know what we talked about last question. It's like people know a language, and they try to solve all the problems in that language. And then some languages handle that better than others. And so I think you start to see that problem.
有一些问题，有一些错误的假设。他们试图修复它，打补丁。最终的结果是，人们知道我们上一个问题讨论的内容。就像人们熟悉一种语言，他们试图用那种语言解决所有问题。然后有些语言比其他语言处理得更好。所以我认为你开始看到那个问题了。
One of the things that I think about Lisp is that it's so minimal that people end up building up a lot of infrastructure to make the language support their current paradigm yep so you write like domain specific language kind of things in lisp to help you do what you want to do so that list becomes the language you need for the the current opportunity but that like we said before has pros and cons and you know depending if you're not a language designer by trade you can kind of work yourself into a trap. But people kind of have that belief like, oh, Lisp is so beautiful because it's so minimal,
关于Lisp，我想到的一点是，它非常极简，以至于人们最终构建了大量的基础设施来使该语言支持他们当前的范式，是的，所以你在Lisp中编写类似领域特定语言的东西来帮助你做你想做的事，这样Lisp就变成了你当前机会所需的语言，但正如我们之前所说，这有利有弊，你知道，如果你不是专业的语言设计师，你可能会把自己困住。但人们确实有那种信念，比如，哦，Lisp太美了，因为它太极简了，
because it's so flexible, because you can really make it do anything and not be like, oh, look, it's failing down there. That's why I think you get that fanboyism of it's an artistic, beautiful expression to see how far you can stretch this minimal set of instructions. Right, right.
因为它太灵活了，因为你真的可以做任何事情，而不是像，哦，看，它在那里失败了。这就是为什么我认为你会得到那种粉丝心态，即看到你能将这组极简指令扩展到什么程度，这是一种艺术性的、美丽的表达。对，对。
Creativity through restraint or something. Yeah, I haven't seen too much of the Lisp love i have seen a lot of the php hate um i mean obviously you see it with like functional love like oh you got to be programming functional or you're not doing it right yeah that's a lot of haskell and and a lot and for a long time it was universally accepted like well that oh was the only way yeah Yeah, that's right. Everything needed to be an object and objects and object, right? And in college, like, that's how I was taught. It's like, just everything's OO, right? I remember, like, basically having discussions about, you know, how do you solve these problems where you have different objects and they're holding
通过克制来创造，或者类似的东西。是的，我没有看到太多对Lisp的喜爱，但我确实看到了很多对PHP的憎恨，嗯，我的意思是，显然你会在函数式编程的喜爱中看到它，比如“哦，你必须进行函数式编程，否则你就做错了”，是的，那有很多Haskell，而且很长一段时间里，它被普遍接受为“哦，那是唯一的方法”，是的，没错。一切都需要是对象，对象和对象，对吧？在大学里，我就是这样被教导的。就像，一切都是面向对象的，对吧？我记得，基本上讨论过，你知道，你如何解决这些问题，你有不同的对象，它们持有
basically the same data, but they do different things. And basically I was trying to arrive at functional programming, but I didn't know what it was at the time. This was, you know, I'm like, I don't know, in high school or something. And, yeah, everyone was just like, oh, yeah, you just make a bunch of objects, and you inherit the other objects and just override the functions without changing the data types. And then you end up with kind of like how Hadoop is now, where you end up with a mapper
基本相同的数据，但它们做不同的事情。基本上我试图得出函数式编程的结论，但我当时不知道它是什么。这是，你知道，我在高中还是什么的。而且，是的，每个人都只是说，哦，是的，你只需要创建一堆对象，然后继承其他对象并覆盖函数而不改变数据类型。然后你最终会得到像现在Hadoop那样的东西，你最终会得到一个带有map函数的mapper
class with a map function and it's just kind of a nightmare. So I think that again, as Patrick said, for different tasks, different languages are amenable to that task. And yeah,
类，这简直是一场噩梦。所以我认为，正如Patrick所说，对于不同的任务，不同的语言适合该任务。是的，
OOP isn't great for everything. Functional languages aren't great for everything. And so it's just, yeah, I think a lot of it is just finding the right tool for the job. It's kind of like being a mechanic. I mean, a mechanic has a huge toolbox. And, you know, maybe, you know, a torque wrench is good for this. I mean, you could use a socket wrench, but it's very difficult. And so a lot of being a mechanic is knowing sort of what tools to use at the right time. And specifically for PHP 8,
面向对象编程并不适合所有事情。函数式语言并不适合所有事情。所以，是的，我认为很多时候只是找到适合工作的正确工具。这有点像当一名机械师。我的意思是，机械师有一个巨大的工具箱。而且，你知道，也许，你知道，扭矩扳手对这个很好。我的意思是，你可以使用套筒扳手，但这非常困难。所以当一名机械师很大程度上是知道在正确的时间使用什么样的工具。特别是对于PHP 8，
I think it is somewhat just class derision, a caste system, as it were. Because I think what happens is people were using, who learned PHP learned it to do like web development, but that was early web, right? And so, well, relatively early, I guess. And so people were like, oh, you're a web developer. You're calling yourself a software engineer, but you're not.
我认为这在某种程度上只是阶级嘲讽，一种种姓制度。因为我认为发生的事情是，人们使用PHP，学习PHP是为了做网络开发，但那是早期的网络，对吧？所以，嗯，相对早期，我想。所以人们会说，哦，你是一名网络开发人员。你称自己为软件工程师，但你不是。
Like the code you're writing isn't at the level of complexity that someone else is writing. And so therefore you're a worse person. That's true. And so I think the same thing happened with JavaScript for a long time. But now web apps have become so complicated, it doesn't really work anymore. And it kind of just faded away.
就像你编写的代码没有达到别人编写代码的复杂程度。因此，你是一个更糟糕的人。这是真的。所以我认为JavaScript在很长一段时间里也发生了同样的事情。但现在网络应用变得如此复杂，它已经不再适用了。它有点消失了。
But a lot of people, it was like, oh, you do web programming and you make JavaScript apps or Flash apps. You're a second-class citizen, right? You're not a software engineer. That's child's play. And that's just ignorance, immaturity of the thing. And as time has gone on, a lot of those people, now some of them probably made the leap.
但很多人，就像，哦，你做网络编程，你制作JavaScript应用或Flash应用。你是二等公民，对吧？你不是软件工程师。那是小孩子的游戏。那只是无知，事情的不成熟。随着时间的推移，很多人，现在他们中的一些人可能已经跨越了那一步。
Some of them probably just because they wrote you know a web app that was really simple doesn't mean they can also write a game engine right or whatever but they didn't need to that was fine what they were doing was the right tool for the right job perhaps and they did a good job but then they tried to say they were something more and then you know not all of them were able to actually do that but some of them were some of them that was just their first language they, and then they moved on and did other stuff, right? And it turned out they were great programmers. I'm sure great programmers and terrible programmers started in PHP. Yeah, that makes sense.
他们中的一些人可能只是因为他们编写了一个非常简单的网络应用，并不意味着他们也能编写游戏引擎，对吧，或者其他什么，但他们不需要，那没关系，他们所做的是适合工作的正确工具，他们做得很好，但后来他们试图说他们是更高级的东西，然后你知道，并非所有人都能真正做到这一点，但有些人可以，有些人那只是他们的第一语言，然后他们继续前进并做了其他事情，对吧？事实证明他们是伟大的程序员。我相信伟大的程序员和糟糕的程序员都是从PHP开始的。是的，这很有道理。
Makes sense. And then we had to follow up. Why haven't you covered PHP? We will. I've actually done a decent amount of PHP. Really? A long time ago, a very long time ago. So why'd you stop?
有道理。然后我们有后续问题。为什么你们没有涵盖PHP？我们会做的。我实际上做过相当多的PHP。真的吗？很久以前，很久以前。那你为什么停下来？
No, I'm just saying. Really? A long time ago, a very long time ago. So why'd you stop? I'll say I stopped because really when Rails came around, I mean, Ruby on Rails and then Grails, and then I felt like, I mean, PHP was great at the time, but I feel like if I had to make a web app now, it would definitely be like Node.js or Ruby on Rails. I think these things have really eclipsed PHP. And it's not a dig on the language.
不，我只是说。真的吗？很久以前，很久以前。那你为什么停下来？我会说我停下来是因为当Rails出现时，我的意思是，Ruby on Rails，然后是Grails，然后我觉得，我的意思是，PHP在当时很棒，但我觉得如果我现在必须制作一个网络应用，它绝对会是Node.js或Ruby on Rails。我认为这些东西确实已经超过了PHP。这不是对该语言的挖苦。
It's just the scaffolding. Yeah, there isn't a lot of excitement around PHP anymore. Yeah, that's right. But there's not a lot of excitement around, really, around C++ or Java anymore either. But they've just reached such critical mass that there's so much work to be done in them that they survive. Yep.
这只是脚手架的问题。是的，PHP周围已经没有太多兴奋了。是的，没错。但C++或Java周围也没有太多兴奋了。但它们已经达到了临界质量，以至于有太多的工作要做，所以它们生存了下来。是的。
Yeah, definitely. Okay. I would like to hear an episode about the open source and free software, the ethics behind it, and how someone could actually have a viable business which creates open source software. This is from Christopher. Good question, Christopher.
是的，绝对。好的。我想听一期关于开源和自由软件、其背后的伦理，以及一个人如何能够真正拥有一个可行的、创造开源软件的企业的节目。这是Christopher提出的。好问题，Christopher。
So, right. So, well, there's obviously companies that run on open source software or make use of open source software. I mean, almost any company, really. If you look at any of the big name companies, they're using some open source software. I mean, if you, I remember, this goes way back, but when I beat Warcraft 3 3 or might even be warcraft 2 but but when i got to the ending credits they actually put the open source um uh um attributions in the ending credits and i remember seeing you know zlib and all these open source prod lib png all these open source projects and and looking them up online and learning about them.
所以，是的。那么，显然有公司运行在开源软件上或利用开源软件。我的意思是，几乎任何公司，真的。如果你看看任何大牌公司，他们都在使用一些开源软件。我的意思是，如果你，我记得，这要追溯到很久以前，但当我通关《魔兽争霸3》或者可能是《魔兽争霸2》时，当我在片尾字幕中看到时，他们实际上在片尾字幕中放了开源的归属，我记得看到了zlib和所有这些开源产品，libpng，所有这些开源项目，并在网上查找它们并了解它们。
And it's so cool. And basically, since forever, I mean, I don't even know, probably 20 years or something, all the major companies have been using open source, right? So there's a lot of things with licenses, what you can and can't do, and GPL. And I don't really want to go into that. We're not lawyers. We'll just say there is some open source software that if you're a private company, you can't use. You can't package with your solution or you have to use it in a certain way.
这太酷了。基本上，从很久以前开始，我的意思是，我甚至不知道，可能20年左右，所有的大公司都在使用开源，对吧？所以有很多关于许可证的事情，你可以做什么，不能做什么，还有GPL。我真的不想深入探讨那个。我们不是律师。我们只会说有一些开源软件，如果你是一家私营公司，你不能使用。你不能将其与你的解决方案打包，或者你必须以某种方式使用它。
And there's other licenses that let you sort of do whatever you want. Some of those have both. So they offer one under if you want to use this and you're not a company making money off of it you can use a free one but if you are you need to pay to license it right appropriately with a different license yep that's right um another thing so someone uh so so some part of this question is actually um can you build a whole company around open source? You know, say Red Hat, for example, right? And yes, you absolutely can.
还有其他许可证允许你随心所欲地做任何事情。其中一些两者兼有。所以他们提供一个，如果你想使用这个，而你不是一家从中赚钱的公司，你可以使用免费的，但如果你是，你需要付费以获得适当的许可，使用不同的许可证，是的，没错，嗯，另一件事，所以有人，所以这个问题的一部分实际上是，你能围绕开源建立整个公司吗？你知道，比如Red Hat，对吧？是的，你绝对可以。
I mean, there's a lot of companies where maybe not everything, but everything except the secret sauce is open source. I mean, if you go on, say, Twitter's GitHub page, they have just tons and tons of projects. No, I don't know, but that's a good example. I mean, I think an example would be more like someone who's really behind like Hadoop or something, right? And they're like pushing,
我的意思是，有很多公司，也许不是所有东西，但除了秘密配方之外的所有东西都是开源的。我的意思是，如果你去，比如，Twitter的GitHub页面，他们有大量的项目。不，我不知道，但这是一个很好的例子。我的意思是，我认为一个例子更像是真正支持Hadoop或类似东西的人，对吧？他们正在推动，
they're owning that community. Like Apache Foundation or something. No, but that's not a good example. But yeah, like if you took someone, and I don't know if they do, but like if you took like Cloudera or someone who's really pushing that technology. They're mostly doing open source,
他们拥有那个社区。比如Apache基金会什么的。不，那不是一个好例子。但是的，就像如果你找一个人，我不知道他们是否这样做，但就像如果你找Cloudera或真正推动该技术的人。他们大多在做开源，
but maybe they sell a couple of modules that are secret sauce, but they have alternatives that aren't, but they are mostly, I think, in my opinion, selling consultancy. That's right. We'll help you run your jobs. We'll help you optimize your jobs.
但也许他们卖一些是秘密配方的模块，但他们有不是秘密配方的替代品，但我认为，在我看来，他们大多是在卖咨询服务。没错。我们会帮你运行你的作业。我们会帮你优化你的作业。
If you want features added, you can pay us and we'll add the features you want. That's one opportunity. Another opportunity is one I described, which is like you have two versions of the software, an open source one, but it has a license such that you can't use it if you're not also open source or whatever. But then you can pay me and license it instead. And then that's kind of like a try before you buy almost.
如果你想添加功能，你可以付钱给我们，我们会添加你想要的功能。这是一个机会。另一个机会是我描述的那个，即你有两个版本的软件，一个开源的，但它有一个许可证，使得如果你不是开源的，你就不能使用它，或者其他什么。但你可以付钱给我并获得许可。然后这几乎就像是先试后买。
And, you know, that's another way. You can sell consultancy as yourself or your company, bug fixes. Yeah. And keep in mind, like something like Hadoop is a great example. Git is another good example. You know, if you're a huge enterprise and you're using Git, and all of a sudden your repository just, you know, gets too big or you need, like, directory-specific access control lists or something like that, you know, you can go to, I guess, Linus Thorvald's
而且，你知道，这是另一种方式。你可以作为你自己或你的公司销售咨询服务，修复bug。是的。而且要记住，像Hadoop这样的东西就是一个很好的例子。Git是另一个很好的例子。你知道，如果你是一家大型企业，你正在使用Git，突然你的存储库变得太大了，或者你需要目录特定的访问控制列表之类的东西，你知道，你可以去找，我想是Linus Torvalds的
company. I don't know what you would do in this case, but there's people who you can pay who will fork the Git project and do something custom for your company. And so by getting a lot of the mind share on a particular feature, such as Git has a lot of mind share on version control, you can then make a lot of money
公司。我不知道在这种情况下你会怎么做，但有些人你可以付钱，他们会分叉Git项目并为你的公司做一些定制的东西。因此，通过在特定功能上获得大量的思想份额，例如Git在版本控制上有很多思想份额，你就可以赚很多钱
and build a viable business out of just supporting that for people for whom that software has a lot of value. Or even just hosting it for them. So that would be something like WordPress. Yeah, WordPress. So you can run WordPress on your... I might be misspeaking.
并仅仅通过为那些软件具有很大价值的人提供支持来建立一个可行的业务。或者甚至只是为他们托管它。所以那会是像WordPress这样的东西。是的，WordPress。所以你可以在你的……上运行WordPress。我可能说错了。
No, you're right. You can run WordPress, but it may not be open source, but at least it's free, right? You can run it on your website for free, open source, but then they'll offer to host it for you, which has the advantage that it'll be secure, up to date, and even they could offer early release of features
不，你是对的。你可以运行WordPress，但它可能不是开源的，但至少它是免费的，对吧？你可以在你的网站上免费运行它，开源的，但他们会提供为你托管它，这有一个优势，那就是它将是安全的、最新的，甚至他们可以提供功能的早期版本
if they wanted to, and they'll host it for you. They have metrics that they won't you know, that sort of stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So that's another way. Yep. So Great question, Christopher. Can you talk about third-party metrics and data collection systems from Kenny? So there's a lot of these. We should do a show on this.
如果他们愿意的话，他们会为你托管它。他们有你不知道的指标，那种东西。是的，是的，是的。所以这是另一种方式。是的。所以好问题，Christopher。你能谈谈Kenny提出的第三方指标和数据收集系统吗？所以有很多这样的系统。我们应该做一期关于这个的节目。
So what do they mean? I don't actually know what this question, like data collection. So this is actually a huge paragraph. I just took the last sentence. Context. Yeah, I'm cheating. So Kenny wrote some apps and he has a website and they're all, you know, using the same server. And the question is sort of how can I get some good metrics. Got it. We'll cover this in a ton of detail. We'll do another show on this.
所以他们是什么意思？我实际上不知道这个问题，比如数据收集。所以这实际上是一个巨大的段落。我只是取了最后一句。上下文。是的，我在作弊。所以Kenny写了一些应用，他有一个网站，它们都在，你知道，使用同一个服务器。问题是某种程度上我如何获得一些好的指标。明白了。我们将非常详细地涵盖这一点。我们会再做一期关于这个的节目。
But one thing that I'm starting to get into, which I think is pretty cool, is called ELK. And the ELK stands for Elasticsearch, Logstash, and Kubeana. And like I said, it's a whole show. But basically, you can give them logs where it's just lines of JSON objects. And they parse the logs. They do some kind of filtering and machine learning.
但有一件事我开始接触了，我认为非常酷，叫做ELK。ELK代表Elasticsearch、Logstash和Kibana。就像我说的，这是一整期节目。但基本上，你可以给他们日志，其中只是JSON对象的行。他们解析日志。他们做某种过滤和机器学习。
They generate a bunch of pretty graphs. They basically do all of it for you. You can even have 100 machines that are generating these logs. They'll handle aggregating it and everything. There's a bunch of pipelines like this that are open source. That's one that I'm most familiar with.
他们生成一堆漂亮的图表。他们基本上为你做了所有这些。你甚至可以有100台机器在生成这些日志。他们会处理聚合它和所有事情。有很多像这样的管道是开源的。这是我最熟悉的一个。
But these are like Google Analytics or something where you just put a little tag. You basically send a request out to a server and it logs that someone did something. Yeah, Google Analytics. There's Google Analytics. There's Google Analytics. There's a couple other ones.
但这些就像Google Analytics或类似的东西，你只是放一个小标签。你基本上向服务器发送一个请求，它记录下有人做了某事。是的，Google Analytics。有Google Analytics。有Google Analytics。还有其他几个。
Yeah, there's several, yeah. Yeah, I can't remember off the top of my head. But that is even more hands-off where you don't even generate the raw logs yourself, but you sort of send hints to, I guess, Google. Say like a hint, like someone clicked on something or a hint, someone went to a page. And then they
是的，有几个，是的。是的，我记不清了。但那甚至更省事，你甚至不需要自己生成原始日志，但你某种程度上向，我想是Google，发送提示。比如一个提示，有人点击了什么，或者一个提示，有人访问了一个页面。然后他们
take all of these hints and group them all together yeah all right next question is how frequently do programmers make use of open source software in their production quality projects from alex oh i think you already answered their question a little we covered you we were uh thinking ahead we covered you with christopher's question so cool all right next question oh go ahead a lot yeah pretty much yeah and at big companies it is a concern you always have to write down when you use or bring in open source stuff and make sure you obey the licenses because it typically goes through your legal team yeah like oh you if you use the software send me a postcard well is that like a legally binding agreement are your lawyers okay? Is like, you had to like send them a registered postcard so you can prove
获取所有这些提示并将它们组合在一起，是的，好的，下一个问题是程序员在生产质量项目中多频繁地使用开源软件，来自Alex。哦，我想你已经回答了他们的问题一点点，我们涵盖了你，我们是在未雨绸缪，我们用Christopher的问题涵盖了你，所以很酷，好的，下一个问题，哦，请继续，很多，是的，几乎是，是的，在大公司，这是一个问题，当你使用或引入开源东西时，你总是必须写下来，并确保你遵守许可证，因为它通常会经过你的法律团队，是的，比如，哦，如果你使用这个软件，给我寄一张明信片，嗯，那是一个具有法律约束力的协议吗？你的律师同意吗？就像，你必须给他们寄一张挂号明信片，这样你才能证明
that you did that, right? Like, you know, I'm not a lawyer, so I can't say if those things are, well, hold up in court, but you don't want to get sued, right? Getting sued sucks. Getting sued is a nightmare. Just, okay, a little bit off topic, but we'll talk a little bit about, have you been sued or been part of a lawsuit or anything? Okay. So if your company gets sued, a number of things will happen that you won't like. Number one, they will give you a new machine. You can copy your things to the new machine, but the old machine has to stay sort of like just preserved.
你做了那个，对吧？就像，你知道，我不是律师，所以我不能说那些事情是否会在法庭上站得住脚，但你不想被起诉，对吧？被起诉很糟糕。被起诉是一场噩梦。只是，好的，有点跑题了，但我们会谈谈，你被起诉过或参与过诉讼吗？好的。所以如果你的公司被起诉，会发生一些你不喜欢的事情。第一，他们会给你一台新机器。你可以把你的东西复制到新机器上，但旧机器必须保持某种被保存的状态。
Yeah. So pain point number one, right? Number two is, you know, you're just going to have to deal with a litany of back and forth and meetings and things like that that you don't want. So, so... Dispositions, is that what they're gonna have?
是的。所以痛点一，对吧？第二是，你知道，你只是不得不处理一连串的来回、会议和类似的事情，你不想要的。所以，所以……取证，那是他们要做的吗？
Like go make statements and they record you and like, yeah, that sounds not fun. Yeah, not fun, not fun. So, so yeah, I mean, it's a huge time sink. Yeah, don't get sued. All right. So the next, oh, we have one from somebody asked. So has Docker found its way into your daily workflow?
比如去发表声明，他们记录你，而且，是的，那听起来不好玩。是的，不好玩，不好玩。所以，所以是的，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的时间消耗。是的，不要被起诉。好的，所以下一个，哦，我们有一个人问。所以Docker进入你的日常工作流程了吗？
Has Docker found its way into your daily workflow? I got Docker up and running. I did it actually to run the TensorFlow. Did you see this? Yeah. You know about TensorFlow. So Google released this thing, TensorFlow, where it lets you do a bunch of data analysis and machine learning and things like that.
Docker进入你的日常工作流程了吗？我让Docker运行起来了。我实际上是为了运行TensorFlow才这么做的。你看到了吗？是的。你知道TensorFlow。所以Google发布了这个东西，TensorFlow，它让你做一堆数据分析和机器学习之类的事情。
And they released it as a Docker image, which I'd heard about Docker, the company, but I'd never really gotten into it. I was able to get it up and running, but to be honest, I haven't gone beyond that. Oh, no, actually, I did. I got a Docker image for... There's a way you can compile Windows binaries on Mac
他们把它作为Docker镜像发布了，我听说过Docker这家公司，但我从来没有真正深入了解过。我能够让它运行起来，但老实说，我没有超越那个。哦，不，实际上，我做了。我得到了一个Docker镜像……有一种方法可以在Mac上编译Windows二进制文件
using Docker. So it actually... There's a Docker image that has MingGW, which is the Unix Windows, I don't even know what it's called, Minimalist. Windows GCC compiler? Something like that. It produces a Windows binary, basically.
使用Docker。所以它实际上……有一个Docker镜像，里面有MingGW，这是Unix Windows，我甚至不知道它叫什么，极简主义。Windows GCC编译器？类似的东西。它基本上产生一个Windows二进制文件。
So there's a Docker image for that, and it was pretty slick. You could just point it to your directory with your make file, and through Docker it would just spit an exe out on the other end, and you didn't need anything at all. I've seen some things like that, too, for projects out there where normally you would need to get a lot of pieces together and just put them in a Docker and release it. But I haven't come across it yet.
所以有一个Docker镜像，它非常顺滑。你可以直接指向带有你的makefile的目录，通过Docker，它会在另一端吐出一个exe，你根本不需要任何东西。我也见过一些类似的东西，对于外面的项目，通常你需要把很多部分放在一起，然后把它们放在Docker里并发布它。但我还没有遇到过。
It's not in my personal workflow yet. I increasingly hear about it, so maybe I need to spend more time looking into it. Same here. Is there a preferred term for programmers today? Do you prefer programmer, developer, software engineer, etc.? Do you think there are significant differences that go with the various terms, or are they roughly
它还没有进入我的个人工作流程。我越来越多地听到它，所以也许我需要花更多时间研究它。我也是。今天程序员有首选术语吗？你更喜欢程序员、开发人员、软件工程师等吗？你认为这些术语之间有显著的区别，还是它们大致
interchangeable? From Mark. Do you want to answer their question first? I have an opinion. You go first. Oh, you have a strong opinion? You definitely go first. Okay. My strong opinion is I don't care which you call me, and I will argue to anyone for a very long time that they all mean the same thing in general vernacular.
可以互换？来自Mark。你想先回答他们的问题吗？我有一个观点。你先来。哦，你有强烈的观点？你绝对先来。好的。我强烈的观点是，我不在乎你叫我什么，我会和任何人争论很长时间，它们在通用语中意思是一样的。
So people tell me all the time, software engineers aren't engineers because, insert whatever statement, this was making the rounds like a month ago on the internet. Fine, whatever, I don't care, sure, call me a developer, call me a programmer, call me a coder, call me... Yeah, it really doesn't matter. Occasionally there are terms which have more or less connotation like typically coder is a little more like someone said code slave oh no no no so like coder is more like oh you don't do programming you don't do software engineering it's like coder is a maybe a little more connotation that way and like software
所以人们一直告诉我，软件工程师不是工程师，因为，插入任何陈述，这一个月前在互联网上流传。好吧，随便，我不在乎，当然，叫我开发人员，叫我程序员，叫我编码员，叫我……是的，这真的没关系。偶尔会有一些术语带有或多或少的内涵，比如通常编码员更像是有人说的代码奴隶，哦，不，不，不，所以编码员更像是，哦，你不做编程，你不做软件工程，就像编码员可能带有更多那样的内涵，而像软件
architect is seen as a little you know different in some places, these things do have meaning. Right, right. But universally, these things don't have an actual agreed upon formal definition. And there's no certifying body that says you must have X to be a programmer and Y to be a software engineer. And if you have a degree in computer science, does that make you a software engineer? Like, no, it doesn't matter.
架构师在某些地方被视为有点，你知道，不同，这些东西确实有意义。对，对。但普遍来说，这些东西没有一个实际商定的正式定义。而且没有认证机构说你必须拥有X才能成为程序员，拥有Y才能成为软件工程师。如果你有计算机科学学位，那会让你成为软件工程师吗？就像，不，没关系。
It's like currencies. Imagine every company as being their own country with their own currency and having, you know, being an architect might be like having a thousand dollars in some currency, but you have no idea what it translates to in, you know, Euro or US dollars or something. And so it's kind of... Yeah, so many companies, for instance, for software architect as a good example, that's a very senior person. They report to a high-level manager. They're many years of experience,
这就像货币。想象每个公司都是他们自己的国家，有他们自己的货币，并且拥有，你知道，成为架构师可能就像在某种货币中有1000美元，但你不知道它在欧元或美元或其他什么中转换成什么。所以这有点……是的，很多公司，例如，软件架构师是一个很好的例子，那是一个非常资深的人。他们向高级经理汇报。他们有多年经验，
and they're brought in as kind of like when they say something, you should kind of do what they say, like that kind of recommending person. And other companies, it's just a different role from software engineer where you spend a little more time on requirements and designing the system. And you're more what some places would call a systems engineer.
并且他们被引入，就像当他们说某事时，你应该照他们说的做，那种推荐人。而在其他公司，它只是一个与软件工程师不同的角色，你花更多时间在需求和设计系统上。而且你更像是某些地方所说的系统工程师。
And they start junior engineers in that position. You can be a software architect right out of school. Interesting. So, yeah, no. They don't mean. Someone asked me on Quora. Someone asked me to answer, does it matter whether you are data scientist or software engineer? And even there, I mean, clearly there is a difference. But there are so many people who
他们让初级工程师担任那个职位。你刚毕业就可以成为软件架构师。有趣。所以，是的，不。它们的意思不。有人在Quora上问我。有人让我回答，你是数据科学家还是软件工程师重要吗？即使在那里，我的意思是，显然有区别。但有很多人
have the wrong title or not the wrong title. There's so many people who are spending all day doing statistics who are software engineers or spending all day building systems who are data scientists, that separation hasn't happened yet. You may use it to mean something, but you can't guarantee the person on the other end. Exactly. Yeah, also means the same thing. So you should be really careful. I did find one place where it really matters, and that is the immigration office.
拥有错误的头衔，或者不是错误的头衔。有很多人整天做统计，他们是软件工程师，或者整天构建系统，他们是数据科学家，那种分离还没有发生。你可能会用它来表示某种东西，但你不能保证另一端的人。完全正确。是的，也意味着同样的事情。所以你应该非常小心。我确实发现了一个真正重要的地方，那就是移民局。
Are they going to say the payroll. Yeah, not first hand. But I've heard from several people who wanted to be data scientists because it helps you in the immigration department. But I would say that's, if I had to venture a guess, and I know nothing about the immigration process. Not me either. But if I had to venture a guess, I would say that's just because it's a newer title, so it's less overloaded by people. Possibly.
他们会说工资单吗。是的，不是第一手。但我从几个想成为数据科学家的人那里听说，因为它在移民部门对你有帮助。但我会说，如果我必须冒险猜测，而且我对移民过程一无所知。我也不是。但如果我必须冒险猜测，我会说那只是因为它是一个较新的头衔，所以被人们过度使用的程度较低。可能。
Anyways, next question. My degree allows me to focus on one of five fields. Software development, web development, information security, networking, and database management. What are your takes on the future applicability and in-the-field work environment for each of these from Shadrach?
无论如何，下一个问题。我的学位允许我专注于五个领域之一。软件开发、网络开发、信息安全、网络和数据库管理。对于这些中的每一个，你们对未来的适用性和实地工作环境有什么看法，来自Shadrach？
Do you want to go first or me? You thought about it. I'll go. So software development is mostly what we talk about here on this podcast. It's what I would say of these categories that Jason and I both do. And of these, right off the top of my head, I would say it's probably the most in-demand, at least of where we are. That isn't to say that you're guaranteed to make the most money because some of these others I think have more variance in the
你想先来还是我先来？你考虑过它。我来。所以软件开发主要是我们在这个播客上谈论的内容。我会说在这些类别中，Jason和我都在做。在这些类别中，我立刻想到，我会说它可能是需求量最大的，至少在我们所处的地方。这并不是说你保证能赚最多的钱，因为我认为这些其他领域在
numbers. Right. But I would hazard a guess that it's the, if you want to talk about salary, the highest average salary. Software development. Software development. Yeah. I would argue that. It's also the one on here that, you know, you know a lot more about what you're getting when you get someone who does that thing right um so then we can talk about web development web development can be anyone from doing software development in a web-based language so think about like the person who's writing the facebook like the facebook.com that website right that's not just html displaying i mean there's a huge application there's hundreds and probably thousands of people working on that.
数字上有更多的差异。对。但我敢猜测，如果你想谈论薪水，平均薪水最高的是软件开发。软件开发。是的。我会争辩这一点。它也是这里的一个，你知道，当你得到一个做那件事的人时，你知道你得到的是什么，对吧，嗯，那么我们可以谈谈网络开发，网络开发可以是任何做基于网络语言的软件开发的人，所以想想比如编写Facebook的人，比如facebook.com那个网站，对吧，那不仅仅是HTML显示，我的意思是，有一个巨大的应用程序，有数百甚至可能有数千人在上面工作。
I mean, can you imagine how many lines of JavaScript that is? No, I don't want to think about it. It's probably millions. And so I guess it used to be PHP too, right? But web development there is very hard. But I think a lot of times if someone doesn't say software engineer or software development and they say web development, they can be using that word to say,
我的意思是，你能想象那是多少行JavaScript吗？不，我不想考虑它。可能数百万。所以我猜它以前也是PHP，对吧？但那里的网络开发非常困难。但我认为很多时候，如果有人不说软件工程师或软件开发，而他们说网络开发，他们可以使用那个词来试图
to try to claim something a little more. It can open themselves up. I do CSS and images and mock-ups, and I'm a web developer. Or there's those sort of build-your-own-website tools, like I think Wex is one. Oh, WissyWig Editor. And so focusing in school, if you're interested in web development and it includes a heavy emphasis on programming, like JavaScript, not necessarily a heavy focus on
声称一些更高级的东西。它可以让他们自己敞开。我做CSS和图像和模型，我是一名网络开发人员。或者有那些构建你自己的网站工具，比如我认为Wex是一个。哦，所见即所得编辑器。所以如果你对网络开发感兴趣，并且它包括对编程的沉重强调，比如JavaScript，不一定是对
HTML and CSS, that's probably fine because you can get jobs doing that. But I would be careful because I would hazard to say it's a little easier to go from software development to web development if that's what you're interested in than vice versa. Information security, I feel, although is related to computers and you do need to understand programming, you don't actually do a lot of programming from the people I've talked to. So information security, they may do a lot of scripting. They may do a lot of sysadmin work. And they do need to be really knowledgeable.
HTML和CSS的沉重关注，那可能没问题，因为你可以找到做那个的工作。但我会小心，因为我敢说，如果你感兴趣的话，从软件开发转向网络开发比反过来要容易一些。信息安全，我觉得，虽然与计算机有关，而且你确实需要了解编程，但据我交谈过的人说，你实际上并没有做很多编程。所以信息安全，他们可能会做很多脚本编写。他们可能会做很多系统管理工作。而且他们确实需要非常知识渊博。
And it's a really hard job to do and really hard to find. And I think here you could get a huge variance in pay. That's right. So if you're a very elite black hat hacker working on tiger teams and stuff, you may make a lot of money or not. I don't know. And if you're just somebody doing sysadmin work but calling yourself information security, maybe not. But the stuff itself is really fascinating to me.
这是一项非常困难的工作，也非常难找到。而且我认为在这里你可以获得巨大的薪水差异。没错。所以如果你是一名非常精英的黑帽黑客，在老虎队之类的地方工作，你可能会赚很多钱，或者不赚。我不知道。如果你只是一个做系统管理工作但称自己为信息安全的人，也许不是。但这些东西本身对我来说非常迷人。
But I don't know how much demand there is or isn't for it. I don't think the number of people working in information security approaches the number of people working in software development. So there's a risk there. Networking, same thing. I don't think this means like programming for, you know, TCP. This means like understanding how to manage networks and managing large networks is very, very difficult and you have to be very careful. And at places like Facebook, they've now said, like, they're building their own custom networking gear and stuff. Oh, really?
但我不知道对它有多少需求。我不认为从事信息安全的人数接近从事软件开发的人数。所以那里有风险。网络，同样的事情。我不认为这意味着像为TCP编程。这意味着像了解如何管理网络，管理大型网络非常非常困难，你必须非常小心。在Facebook这样的地方，他们现在说，他们正在构建自己的定制网络设备之类的东西。哦，真的吗？
They handle, like, just massive amounts of stuff in their data center. Wow. So that stuff is crazy. But, again, I don't know how many people are there doing that. And I'm biased. I'm a programmer. I think, yeah. Anyways.
他们处理，比如，他们数据中心里海量的内容。哇。所以那些东西太疯狂了。但是，同样，我不知道有多少人在那里做那个。而且我有偏见。我是一名程序员。我想，是的。无论如何。
Well, another. Oh, what was that? Was there another one? Last one is database management. Oh, okay. And so I was that? Was there another one? Last one is database management. Oh, okay. And so I think that's a very specific niche and very important and probably very highly paid in a lot of circumstances. I think so. But I would imagine harder to find a job than just software engineering.
嗯，另一个。哦，那是什么？还有另一个吗？最后一个是数据库管理。哦，好的。所以我那是？还有另一个吗？最后一个是数据库管理。哦，好的。所以我认为这是一个非常具体的利基，非常重要，而且在很多情况下可能薪水非常高。我想是这样。但我认为比仅仅软件工程更难找到工作。
Yeah, definitely. Yeah, I actually. So everything Patrick says is totally right. My very short answer would be do what you want to do. I mean, if you're really passionate about any of them, follow your passion. All of these are, you know, well-compensated jobs. Doing the one you're most interested in will probably lead to a better result because you'll be engaged, you'll apply yourself at work,
是的，绝对。是的，我实际上。所以Patrick说的一切都是完全正确的。我的简短回答是做你想做的事。我的意思是，如果你真的对其中任何一个充满热情，追随你的热情。所有这些都是，你知道，报酬丰厚的工作。做你最感兴趣的工作可能会导致更好的结果，因为你会投入其中，你会努力工作，
probably get promotions or that kind of stuff. Yeah, I mean, you know, you have to follow your passion. And you have to be happy. Now I'm not trying to say anything deep there, but very superficial comment. Yeah, definitely. You have to be satisfied. If you're not... Thank you, that's better. If you're doing something you hate, it really, nothing
可能会获得晋升或类似的东西。是的，我的意思是，你知道，你必须追随你的热情。而且你必须快乐。现在我不是想在那里说任何深刻的东西，但非常肤浅的评论。是的，绝对。你必须感到满足。如果你不……谢谢，那更好。如果你在做你讨厌的事情，它真的，什么都没有
else matters. You're just going to... I mean, think about it. You're at work as many hours as you are at doing anything else, right? Just during the week. You probably will spend more time with your teammates than you will with your family. Right. Especially if you forget about weekends.
其他都不重要。你只是要……我是说，想一想。你在工作上花费的时间和你做其他任何事情的时间一样多，对吧？仅仅是在工作日期间。你花在同事身上的时间可能比花在家人身上的时间还要多。没错。特别是如果你把周末抛在脑后的话。
If you just look at during the week, it's definitely true. I mean, you're at work eight hours. Or awake. I should say awake hours, yeah. Right. Oh, you're right. Yeah, awake hours. Yeah.
如果你只看工作日，这绝对是真的。我是说，你在工作上待八个小时。或者说清醒的时间。我应该说是清醒的时间，是的。没错。哦，你说得对。是的，清醒的时间。是的。
And then you're doing all this time, and then, you know, you're doing all this time and then there's a, some kind of crunch and you have to work weekends or overtime or something like that. If you're not happy at your job, you're going to get just completely, you know, demotivated and burned out. Um, so, so yeah, follow your passion. Um, someone else asked about, which has become a common thing. As technology replaces jobs, do you see developers becoming like welders, machinists from the first machine age? That's my theory on how we get around the job destruction issue
然后你花所有这些时间，然后，你知道，你花所有这些时间，接着就会出现某种紧迫的情况，你必须在周末加班或者做类似的事情。如果你对自己的工作不满意，你就会完全，你知道，失去动力并精疲力竭。嗯，所以，是的，追随你的热情吧。嗯，还有人问了一个问题，这已经变成了一件常见的事情。随着技术取代工作岗位，你认为开发人员会变得像第一次机器时代的焊工、机械师那样吗？这就是我关于我们如何解决工作被破坏问题的理论。
associated with technology. That's a ward. So, yeah, I talked a lot about this with some colleagues about the job destruction. So is this saying developers will become more important because, like, welders and machinists or became increased necessary because there were more machines? I think what he's saying is... I think that's what he's saying.
与技术相关联。那是一个词。所以，是的，我和一些同事谈了很多关于工作被破坏的问题。所以这是在说开发人员会变得更重要，因为像焊工和机械师一样，因为机器变多了，所以需求增加了吗？我想他想表达的是……我想他就是这个意思。
He's not saying developers' jobs will be destroyed. I think what he's saying is the whole pyramid shifts. So in other words, maybe, you know, used to be there were tons of farmers. Then there's not as many farmers, but each one is basically a mechanic controlling, you know, the machines that are harvesting the wheat. And so the pyramid kind of shifted. The farmers got dropped off the end of the pyramid. And now what we now call farmers is really a different job. And so I think what he's saying is it will shift again. And then, you know, developers will become many more developers will happen because so many things will be replaced with developers.
他并不是说开发人员的工作会被摧毁。我想他想说的是整个金字塔发生了位移。换句话说，也许，你知道，过去有大量的农民。现在农民没那么多了，但每个人基本上都是控制收割小麦机器的机械师。所以金字塔发生了某种位移。农民从金字塔的末端被淘汰了。而我们现在所说的农民其实是另一种工作。所以我认为他想说的是它会再次发生位移。然后，你知道，开发人员会变得更多，因为很多事情都会被开发人员所取代。
And then maybe there'll be, you know, another thing. So I think, um, in general, um, this is kind of, it's a little, kind of a little macabre, I guess, or morbid, but, um, you have these massive, uh, shifts all the time historically, right? You look at say the industrial revolution, right? Tons of job loss, right? And typically what happens isn't very pretty. I mean, historically, you have, you know, massive job loss, then that causes massive income disparity, and then that causes revolution. And so if you look at like the Chinese revolution, the French revolution, a lot of these are because of massive job loss. So that paints sort of a dark picture for the future with, you know, a lot of this robotics and things So that paints sort of a dark picture for the future
然后也许会有，你知道，另一件事。所以我认为，嗯，总的来说，嗯，这有点，有点阴森，我想，或者说病态，但是，嗯，你在历史上一直有这些巨大的，呃，转变，对吧？你看看工业革命，对吧？大量的工作流失，对吧？通常发生的事情并不太美好。我是说，从历史上看，你有，你知道，大规模的工作流失，然后这导致了巨大的收入差距，然后这导致了革命。所以如果你看看像中国革命、法国革命，很多这些都是因为大规模的工作流失。所以这为未来描绘了一幅黑暗的图景，你知道，伴随着很多这种机器人技术之类的东西。所以这为未来描绘了一幅黑暗的图景。
with a lot of this robotics and things like that. You hear about if Uber does self-driving cars, all taxi drivers are out of a job and things like that. I do think that we have a society now where people can be much more fluid. We obviously don't have the same caste system as they did in the medieval times and things like that. And I think people will adapt.
伴随着很多这种机器人技术之类的东西。你听说如果优步（Uber）实现了自动驾驶汽车，所有的出租车司机都会失业，诸如此类。我确实认为我们现在所处的社会，人们可以更加灵活。我们显然没有中世纪时期那样的种姓制度之类的东西。而且我认为人们会适应。
And I think it will cause, if there is, and I'm not saying it's a guarantee, but if there is massive job loss because robots replace humans at a large scale very rapidly, I think you'll see adaptation. And so I feel hopeful. I don't really have a strong opinion. I mean, I hear the arguments.
而且我认为这会导致，如果确实存在，我并不是说这是保证，但如果因为机器人大规模、快速地取代人类而导致大规模失业，我认为你会看到适应。所以我感到充满希望。我并没有什么强烈的观点。我是说，我听过这些论点。
This is one of the arguments for universal basic income where everybody should just make X amount of dollars because we're all going to... I think that's... Yeah, there's a lot of opportunity for deviations from that course between now and then. And I think it's really hard to predict the future. But I would say as far as like developers themselves,
这是全民基本收入的论点之一，每个人都应该赚取X金额的钱，因为我们都将……我认为那是……是的，从现在到那时，偏离这一进程的机会很多。而且我认为预测未来真的很难。但我会说，就开发人员本身而言，
like I don't see a future where we become less needed. Like all of a sudden there's massive developer layoffs in total. There may be in little areas or companies or sectors or if they're market tanks, right? But in general and long-term, I don't see it going down. Same thing healthcare. I don't see there needing to be like less nurses. Nurs nurses may be like less compensated i can't say but like i don't see like we're going to just suddenly need less nurses and doctors right right definitely
我不认为未来我们会变得不那么被需要。就像突然之间出现了大规模的开发人员裁员。在小领域、公司或行业，或者如果市场崩溃，可能会有，对吧？但总的来说，从长远来看，我不认为它会减少。医疗保健也是一样。我不认为对护士的需求会减少。护士的薪酬可能会降低，我不能说，但我不认为我们会突然需要更少的护士和医生，对吧？没错，绝对是。
maybe if robot nurses you know who knows all right uh you should try quine relay and tis 100 steven so we were referring to earlier about assembly, because this is TIS100. So we did do... I'm pretty... Oh, no, actually, we didn't. We didn't... The two of us talked about the Quine Relay, but we didn't put it on a show yet.
也许如果是机器人护士，你知道，谁知道呢。好吧，呃，你应该试试Quine Relay和TIS 100，史蒂文，因为我们之前提到了汇编，因为这是TIS100。所以我们确实做了……我很确定……哦，不，其实我们没有。我们没有……我们俩谈论了Quine Relay，但我们还没有在节目中展示它。
Oh, okay. So very quickly, because it really deserves its own news segment in a future show, but Quine Relay is the super cool thing this guy wrote where you take this ruby program and um when you uh when you execute it it generates a program in another language and when you execute that it generates the output of that is another program another language and uh it it actually goes through, I think, 30 languages
哦，好吧。所以很快地说一下，因为它确实值得在未来的节目中有一个专门的新闻片段，但Quine Relay是这个家伙写的超级酷的东西，你拿这个Ruby程序，嗯，当你执行它时，它会生成另一种语言的程序，当你执行那个程序时，它生成的输出是另一种语言的另一个程序，而且，它实际上经历了，我想，30种语言，
and comes back to Ruby looking exactly the same. It's kind of mind-blowing. That's kind of crazy. Yeah. And TIS 100 is a game in which you need to use assembly language for a made-up processor to kind of solve the game. I haven't played it yet. I actually have this as something I intend to try very soon.
然后回到Ruby时看起来完全一样。这有点令人震惊。这有点疯狂。是的。而TIS 100是一款游戏，你需要使用一种虚构处理器的汇编语言来解决游戏。我还没玩过。我其实打算很快尝试一下。
I'm in the same boat. It came out on iPad recently? It did. I actually replied to Steven at the time, and I said, you know, if it's not out on iPhone or iPad or some type of mobile device, it's going to be very difficult. I think it came out on Android and iPad, so I intend to try this.
我和你一样。它最近在iPad上发布了？是的。我当时确实回复了史蒂文，我说，你知道，如果它不在iPhone或iPad或某种移动设备上发布，那将非常困难。我想它在Android和iPad上都发布了，所以我打算尝试一下。
I don't know how typing it. We'll definitely do it, Steven. This is like my day job. I don't know if I want to do it. We'll do it for Steven. Okay, all right. I don't know how typing. We'll definitely do it, Stephen. This is like my day job. Like, I don't know if I want to do it. We'll do it for Stephen. Okay. All right. I was wondering if you could talk about editors or just about what you like to use and why.
我不知道怎么打字。我们一定会做的，史蒂文。这就像我的日常工作。我不知道我是否想做。我们会为史蒂文做的。好吧，好的。我不知道怎么打字。我们一定会做的，史蒂文。这就像我的日常工作。就像，我不知道我是否想做。我们会为史蒂文做的。好吧。好的。我本来想问你能不能谈谈编辑器，或者谈谈你喜欢用什么以及为什么。
So let's just, we're going kind of long. So like what editor do you normally use at work? I use mostly Emacs and IPython Notebook, which is I guess now called Jupyter. Oh, I didn't know that. So. I use Eclipse. Actually, I use Eclipse for Java, but I use Emacs for everything else. I use Eclipse for Java and for C++.
所以让我们，我们时间有点长了。所以你平时在工作中用什么编辑器？我主要使用Emacs和IPython Notebook，我想现在叫Jupyter。哦，我不知道。所以。我使用Eclipse。其实我用Eclipse写Java，但我用Emacs写其他所有东西。我用Eclipse写Java和C++。
Really? Because I'm a glutton for punishment. Mostly because that's what is offered at my thing. But I like a lot of what an IDE offers. And I know you can do the same thing in VI. Like, for instance, I don't use Emacs, but I can jump into VI and do what I need to do. I just never – You have to set up G tags and do all that.
真的吗？因为我自讨苦吃。主要是因为这是我公司提供的。但我喜欢IDE提供的大部分功能。我知道你可以在VI中做同样的事情。例如，我不使用Emacs，但我可以跳进VI并做我需要做的事情。我只是从来没有——你必须设置G tags并做所有这些。
You have to learn a lot. Yeah. And the problem is if I go to someone else's computer and they're using that, I don't know how to use the way they have it set up and they won't know how to use the way it's set up. And so a lot of what I spend happen to spend. People always look at me funny. But I spend a lot of time at other people's computers for some reason. Really?
你必须学习很多东西。是的。问题是如果我去别人的电脑，他们正在使用那个，我不知道怎么使用他们设置的方式，他们也不会知道怎么使用我设置的方式。所以很多我不得不花费的时间。人们总是用奇怪的眼光看我。但出于某种原因，我花了很多时间在别人的电脑上。真的吗？
It's the thing like you said, like teaching or whatever. Oh, right, right, right. Debugging people's stuff, having conversations. So like I like to be able to go to their computer and not be like, ah! Be productive. Yeah, so like maybe that's just me. Maybe I'm just a weird person. But yeah, I use Eclipse. You can hate on it, whatever. I don't care. I've actually never
就像你说的，教学之类的。哦，对，对，对。调试别人的东西，进行对话。所以我喜欢能够去他们的电脑上，而不是像，啊！保持高效。是的，所以也许那只是我。也许我只是个奇怪的人。但是的，我使用Eclipse。你可以讨厌它，随便。我不在乎。我其实从来没有
tried it for C++, so it could be great. I'll have to check it out. It's not great, but I mean, all of these tools, this is really hard because there's all these sort of bits and pieces that are moving. The IDE at least keeps it consistent. Does it have, like, the, you know, where you can command-click on a function and it takes you to the definition?
试过用它写C++，所以它可能很棒。我得去看看。它并不棒，但我是说，所有这些工具，这真的很难，因为所有这些部分都在移动。IDE至少保持了一致性。它有那种，你知道，你可以命令点击一个函数，它就会带你到定义的地方吗？
Yeah, F3. You push F3 and it takes you to, like, the variable definition. In C++. So it must do some kind of, like, preprocessing or something. Yeah. So it works pretty well, and I like that. And when I go to someone who's using VI Remax, I think I can't stand in this main ABU, So it must do some kind of preprocessing or something. So it works pretty well, and I like that. And when I go to someone who's using VI Remax,
是的，F3。你按F3，它就会带你到变量定义的地方。在C++中。所以它一定做了某种预处理之类的东西。是的。所以它工作得很好，我喜欢这一点。当我去找一个使用VI或Emacs的人时，我想我无法忍受这种主要……所以它一定做了某种预处理之类的东西。所以它工作得很好，我喜欢这一点。当我去找一个使用VI或Emacs的人时，
the thing I can't stand in this main IBU is when I say, like, where is this defined? And they open up a thing and do a grep across the code base looking for the thing, and then they can't figure out where is the definition versus use, and that annoys me. Yeah, they have to set up gtags. If you are doing that, I'm sorry. I don't feel you have an argument to tell me that I'm doing it wrong by having an ID. If you have it properly set up, you know, C tags, D tags, whatever, like, fine.
我无法忍受的是当我问，这个在哪里定义？他们打开一个东西，在代码库中进行grep搜索，然后他们无法弄清楚定义在哪里，使用在哪里，这让我很烦。是的，他们必须设置gtags。如果你在那样做，我很抱歉。我不觉得你有理由告诉我使用IDE是错的。如果你正确设置了它，你知道，C tags，D tags，随便，那很好。
Oh, that's what it is, C tags. C tags, like, oh, I didn't. That's the one I know. If you have C tags set up properly and you want to make the argument that I'm inferior, fine. I don't, okay, whatever. No, I don't, yeah. But if you don't do it and you do the, like, oh, I'm just going to drop into grep and look. No, sorry.
哦，原来是这样，C tags。C tags，哦，我不知道。那是我知道的那个。如果你正确设置了C tags，并且你想争论我不如你，那好吧。我不，好吧，随便。不，我不，是的。但如果你不这样做，而你只是，哦，我只是要用grep去查找。不，抱歉。
Unless you're really good at grep that I've not seen people do where like you can write the regular expression such that it finds the definition, not just the use. If you can do that more of our, do you? That's not how I normally see people. I'm actually pretty good at grep. For a long time, I was the grep my way through it. And then I finally kind of said, you know,
除非你真的很擅长grep，我还没见过有人能写出正则表达式，从而找到定义，而不仅仅是使用。如果你能做到，你做吗？那不是我通常看到人们做的方式。我其实很擅长grep。很长一段时间，我都是用grep来解决问题。然后我终于说，你知道，
like let me take half a day and figure out C tags and G tag, all this stuff. So I probably offended a ton of people. And, like, half the people just dropped off the chat. Yeah, we went from 40 viewers to 20 viewers. No, I'm just kidding. So, but, yeah, I mean, really all the editors, most of the editors work pretty well. I am not strongly biased in this domain. Me neither.
让我花半天时间弄清楚C tags和G tags，所有这些东西。所以我可能冒犯了很多人。而且，有一半人直接退出了聊天。是的，我们从40个观众变成了20个观众。不，我开玩笑的。所以，但是，是的，我是说，真的所有的编辑器，大多数编辑器工作得都很好。在这个领域我没有强烈的偏见。我也一样。
I am frustrated more by people who are strongly biased. Yeah, I don't understand. I'm self my strongly biased. What a waste of energy. Yes. Okay. Want to know about programming basics and concepts like object-oriented, imperative, functional, and so on.
我对那些有强烈偏见的人感到更沮丧。是的，我不明白。我自己有强烈的偏见。真是浪费精力。是的。好的。想了解编程基础和概念，比如面向对象、命令式、函数式等等。
It would be nice to have episodes about these titles. We covered it a little bit here. But, yeah, it's a good point to, like, have a functional episode or something. Yeah, we should do that. Good job. That's Alex. Alex. That said, oh, apparently we injected something
如果能有关于这些主题的剧集就好了。我们在这里稍微涵盖了一点。但是，是的，这是一个很好的点，比如，做一个函数式剧集之类的。是的，我们应该这样做。干得好。那是亚历克斯。亚历克斯。也就是说，哦，显然我们插入了一些东西
and out of order these. Oh, that's probably me. Any pearls of wisdom? Any things you wish you'd known sooner? Any recommended resources? You know, perspective from Ari. Pearls of wisdom. Oh, I think this one is supposed to have been Ari.
并且顺序乱了。哦，那可能是我。有什么智慧的结晶吗？有什么你希望早点知道的事情吗？有什么推荐的资源吗？你知道，来自阿里（Ari）的视角。智慧的结晶。哦，我想这一条应该是阿里的。
Anyways, it's fine. I think we got the name wrong, but that's okay. Sorry. Keep going. Pearls of wisdom. To close out the episode. I think this is the last question. but that's okay. Sorry. Keep going. Pearls of wisdom. To close out the episode. I think this is the last question. All right.
总之，没关系。我想我们名字弄错了，但没关系。抱歉。继续。智慧的结晶。结束这一集。我想这是最后一个问题。但没关系。抱歉。继续。智慧的结晶。结束这一集。我想这是最后一个问题。好吧。
Let's do it. So one of my pearls of wisdom is look for good mentorship. I think that's very important. And I think a lot of times people will join a certain job or a certain company, and they don't really know who they're going to be working with. I think a good mentor makes just incredible, incredible amount of difference. I had some very good mentors through the years. I think you have as well. And they've really been instrumental. I mean, I constantly think about sort of what they have taught me
让我们开始吧。所以我的智慧结晶之一是寻找好的导师。我认为这非常重要。而且我认为很多时候人们会加入某份工作或某家公司，他们并不真正知道他们将与谁一起工作。我认为一位好的导师会产生难以置信的巨大差异。这些年来我有一些非常好的导师。我想你也有。他们确实起到了关键作用。我是说，我不断地思考他们教给我的东西
and things like that. And I feel like, you know, software engineering, there's a science to it, but there's also a vocation, right? I mean, there's a part of it that's like carpentry, where there's not necessarily, like, you don't get a PhD in carpentry. I mean, I'm sure you can, but most people, they become master carpenters through just doing it for a long time and having good mentorship. And I feel like people, I don't know if they're afraid, like ashamed, afraid, or they don't want to think about it as a vocation because it requires you know a lot of you know a full education and things like that but but ultimately a lot of it is vocational and having a good mentor will guide you especially in the first few years i don't know that
之类的。我觉得，你知道，软件工程，它有一门科学，但它也是一种职业，对吧？我是说，它有一部分就像木工，并不一定，你不会获得木工博士学位。我是说，我相信你可以，但大多数人，他们通过长期从事这项工作并拥有良好的指导而成为木工大师。我觉得人们，我不知道他们是否害怕，比如羞愧，害怕，或者他们不想把它看作一种职业，因为它需要你知道很多，你知道，完整的教育之类的东西，但归根结底，它很大程度上是职业性的，拥有一个好的导师会指导你，特别是在最初的几年。我不知道
i having a good mentor at some level is important but you know when you think about like at least the stuff i've seen in the schools people can become master carpenters on their own but a lot of times they do they go and they learn the techniques and they may move past those techniques but like they start out learning this is how you plane an edge of a board to be straight and you know the same basic like this is the construction technique to get to this end goal or whatever but i'm not sure the same thing happens like i feel like coding is just so different like the order i would program something is gonna be very different than the order you would program it not just like start a new project what do you do first but even just like here you need a new class to do this like what do you do
我在某种程度上拥有一个好的导师很重要，但你知道，当你想到，至少我在学校里看到的东西，人们可以自己成为木工大师。但很多时候他们确实会去学习技术，他们可能会超越这些技术，但他们开始学习的是如何把木板的边缘刨平，你知道同样的基本功，比如这是达到最终目标的施工技术之类的。但我不太确定同样的事情会发生，我觉得编码太不同了。我编程的顺序和你编程的顺序会非常不同，不仅仅是像开始一个新项目你先做什么，甚至只是像这里你需要一个新类来做这个，你先做什么
first do you write do you go and do the variables first or do you define maybe that stuff doesn't matter but it does because that's how my brain you're describing kind of it more as an art which i think even even if i don't like that argument i don't really, I know what you're saying, and I've heard this argument before. Even then you need a good mentor. I mean, the best artists have the best mentors. I'm just saying, like, there are certain things which are common amongst good designs, like having a design in mind, having an architecture that you can describe. I think trying not to use every last feature of a language just to show off.
你先写变量吗，还是你定义……也许那些东西不重要，但它确实重要，因为那是我的大脑……你把它描述得更像是一种艺术，我认为即使我不喜欢那个论点，我也不真的，我知道你在说什么，我以前听过这个论点。即便如此，你仍然需要一个好的导师。我是说，最好的艺术家有最好的导师。我只是说，有些东西在好的设计中是共同的，比如心中有设计，拥有一个你可以描述的架构。我认为尽量不要为了炫耀而使用语言的每一个特性。
Absolutely. Oh, that's the worst. I can't stand that. That's my pet peeve, too. I'd rather you write code that looks like a five-year-old could write it. That's awesome. Yep. And if it works and it's not so far going out of the way because you're not using a feature, great.
绝对。哦，那是糟糕透了。我无法忍受。那也是我的心头大患。我宁愿你写的代码看起来像五岁小孩写的。那太棒了。是的。如果它能工作，而且不是因为你没用某个特性而走得太远，那就太好了。
Yep, yep. So those kinds of things, in my mind, are very common amongst it. But how you get there is so different. And like now I find in my role, like I tend to review other people's code and like try to say, oh no, but you didn't do it the way I, and then it's like,
是的，是的。所以这些事情，在我看来，在其中是非常普遍的。但你如何达到目标却大不相同。就像现在我发现我的角色，我倾向于审查别人的代码，并试图说，哦不，但你没有按照我的方式做，然后就像，
wait, hang on. That was a perfectly fine way of doing it. Is it better? Is it worse? No. Okay. That's fine.
等等，等一下。那是一种完全没问题的方法。它更好吗？它更差吗？不。好的。那没问题。
Yep. Yep. Totally. Yeah. That's a good point. So other, my bit of wisdom would be, don't get hung up, that's a good point. My bit of wisdom would be don't get hung up on your way being the right way. We talk about this a lot now, but I see so many people that burn out on just raging against everything.
是的，是的。完全正确。是的。这是一个很好的点。所以其他的，我的智慧结晶是，不要纠结，这是一个很好的点。我的智慧结晶是不要纠结于你的方式就是正确的方式。我们现在经常谈论这个，但我看到太多人因为对一切事物进行猛烈抨击而精疲力竭。
It has to be my way. If you don't use your VI, you're an idiot. Sorry for the strong language. If you don't use blah, oh, I can't believe you did your code that way like only a silly person would do code that way like always try to understand other people's like perspective or where they're coming from or whatever and let it be and also like for me it's a pet peeve there should be a style but like don't don't and it should be consistent but don't get like super hung up about it in like weird ways yep or like if someone's trying to do a little something
必须是我的方式。如果你不用你的VI，你就是个白痴。为强烈的语言道歉。如果你不用那个，哦，我不敢相信你那样写代码，只有傻瓜才会那样写代码，总是试着理解别人的观点或他们的背景之类的，随它去吧。而且对我来说，这是一个心头大患，应该有一种风格，但不要，而且它应该是一致的，但不要在奇怪的事情上超级纠结。是的，或者如果有人试图做一点点
non-standard don't like if they have like a good reason for it it's probably just okay yep yep totally um i had another pearl i think i lost it um oh see things through to completion oh definitely yeah do this really easy early on to just be like, oh, I got down to the last little bit of something, and that's good enough. Like, I got to this hard part. I'll just, like, eh, I'll just go ahead and move on. And it's like, no, no, no, no, no.
非标准的事情，不要，如果他们有充分的理由，那可能就没问题。是的，是的，完全正确。嗯，我还有另一个结晶，我想我忘了它。嗯，哦，把事情做完。哦，绝对是的。在早期很容易就觉得，哦，我做到了最后一点，这就足够了。就像，我到了这个困难的部分。我只是，呃，我还是继续前进吧。就像，不，不，不，不，不。
Like, often that's where, like, the good learning happens because you are really terrible at identifying the easy and hard parts in the beginning. At least I am. Yep, same here. I often misidentify them. The other thing is refactor your code. And a corollary of that is write your code
就像，通常那是好的学习发生的地方，因为你在开始时真的非常不擅长识别简单和困难的部分。至少我是这样。是的，我也是。我经常误判它们。另一件事是重构你的代码。它的一个推论是写代码时
expecting to refactor it. And so what that means is don't try and solve all the world's problems or the next five years worth of problems at your company right now because it changes frequently. You're not really going to get it right anyways and you're going to waste a lot of time, right? The flip side of that is...
要预料到重构它。所以这意味着不要试图解决世界上所有的问题，或者你公司未来五年的问题，因为它们经常变化。无论如何你都不会完全做对，而且你会浪费很多时间，对吧？反面是……
That's a delicate balance, yeah. Yeah, if you're going to code based on this year's problems, then make sure everybody knows that next year you're going to rewrite a lot of it. I think you have to strike some balance there. Like, another thing I've been trying to do is strike the balance of things which I have more confidence that won't change, I'll spend more time on.
这是一个微妙的平衡，是的。是的，如果你要基于今年的问题来编码，那么确保每个人都知道明年你要重写其中的大部分。我认为你必须在那里取得某种平衡。就像，我一直在尝试做的另一件事是取得平衡，对于那些我更有信心不会改变的事情，我会花更多时间。
And things which I think are likely to change, less time on. Yep. Like, I'll do them a little more hacky, a little more, you know, rough around the edges and let that be okay until we are sure we want to do that. Yep. And that's a subjective decision. And you should be proud to redo your code. I mean, like definitely don't get – I've seen this where some people get sort of defensive about their code.
而对于那些我认为可能会改变的事情，花更少的时间。是的。就像，我会把它们做得更黑客一点，更，你知道，粗糙一点，让它没问题，直到我们确定我们想那样做。是的。这是一个主观的决定。你应该为重做你的代码感到自豪。我是说，绝对不要——我见过这种情况，有些人对他们的代码变得有点防御性。
I mean, they look at it as sort of their territory, like, oh, you're wiping my name off the map, you know. And it's like I feel like, you know, if your name isn't wiped off the map in five years then then there's some old code that probably needs to be rewritten yeah we have a lot more questions there was more questions in the chat room but I think we're running a little long on time I think we're gonna cut the episode off here but then we can try to answer some in the chat room yeah yeah all right well that's episode 50 50 on the half a hundred a
我是说，他们把它看作是他们的领地，就像，哦，你在把我的名字从地图上抹去，你知道。我觉得，你知道，如果你的名字在五年内没有被抹去，那么就有一些旧代码可能需要重写。是的，我们还有很多问题，聊天室里还有更多问题，但我认为我们的时间有点长了。我想我们要在这里结束这一集，但我们可以尝试在聊天室里回答一些。是的，是的。好吧，那是第50集，50，半个百，一个
half a quarter of 200 yeah we could just keep going but thank you all for Episode 50. 50. Unbelievable. 50. Half a hundred. A half a century. A quarter of 200. Yeah. We could just keep going. Thank you all for listening. We didn't have a book of the show or tool of the show. But there are lots of other ones, so check them on the blog. Yep.
200的四分之一。是的，我们可以继续，但谢谢大家收听第50集。50。难以置信。50。半个百。半个世纪。200的四分之一。是的。我们可以继续。谢谢大家收听。我们没有节目推荐的书或工具。但还有很多其他的，所以去博客上看看吧。是的。
Visit our Patreon site. That's right. Thank you for all of you who have done that. Yeah, we got some donations yesterday, in fact. We asked for questions and we got donations saying thank you for 50 episodes and everything. We really appreciate that. Appreciate all of your support. And then if you're
访问我们的Patreon网站。没错。谢谢所有这样做的人。是的，事实上我们昨天收到了一些捐款。我们征集问题，我们收到了捐款，说谢谢50集以及所有的一切。我们真的很感激。感谢你们所有的支持。然后如果你
bored like me on your commute, you can check out our links for Audible and get a free thing that's always awesome. I'm listening to one this morning on my way to work. Yep. Yeah, I definitely I'm just getting the account now. We have to find out what your first book's going to be next episode that's right that's right i'll give you advice
像我一样在通勤时感到无聊，你可以查看我们Audible的链接并获得一个免费的东西，那总是很棒的。我今天早上上班路上正在听一个。是的。是的，我绝对现在就要去弄个账户。我们得找出下一集你的第一本书是什么。没错，没错，我会给你建议。
show oh really follow it sweet i have lots to do it all right well i think that's a wrap thanks guys thanks a lot oh thanks y'all oh yeah thanks folks the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目，哦真的吗？跟随它，甜。我有很多要做。好吧，我想这就是结束了。谢谢大家。非常感谢。哦，谢谢你们。哦，是的，谢谢大家。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。